up
okay
let's start let's start our hearing uh
let's start first with the pledge and
represent quality wanna start
The Pledge thank you I pledge allegiance
to the play of the United States of
America
yeah I've got a number of bills so let's
try to keep on time today
uh the first one hb2
55 and I recommend recognize
representative Connie Lane to introduce
it
um thank you Mr chair
um my name is Connie Lane I represent
Concord Ward 2 and I'm here to introduce
the bill on behalf of Representative
McGee
this bill is a campaign finance bill
that seeks transparency for
contributions made by limited liability
companies also called llc's
it is designed to close the so-called
LLC loophole which is used by both
parties
here's how the loophole works
I have an X dollar amount let's say ten
thousand dollar limit that I can give to
any candidate
I can then set up an LLC with just
myself or my friends and I can give a
number another ten thousand dollars then
I can set up a third fourth fifth
No Limit
and I can give as much money as I want
to any candidate or political committee
that's not the case with individuals or
corporations
so
um this the this bill is just designed
to cut out that loophole and so that if
an LLC decides to give money to a
candidate or a political committee then
it has to disclose in its campaign
Finance disclosures to the candidate
the names the persons
who are in that LLC and that money just
gets don't designated excuse me to their
to their um
threshold their limit so that way they
don't get to do
that way they stick to their ten
thousand dollar limit and they don't get
to give a hundred thousand dollars
so
um
that's pretty much what the bill aims to
do
um it is uh right now the law currently
prevents Partnerships uh from giving
donations most llc's are Partnerships
they are they limit the liability hence
the name limited liability they limit
the liability of the members and they
were created as a way to protect
Partners most people it's it's called a
a pass-through entity it's so that when
you have a corporation
the corporation pays taxes and then you
pay taxes with an LLC only you pay the
tax the LLC doesn't pay the tax it
passes through so it's a great benefit
for small companies
um it's also preferred over corporations
for that reason just to to protect or
limit taxes
courts have withheld limits on amounts
contributed to persons so you can limit
the amount of the contribution you just
can't say they can't give
and that's it I was here to introduce
the bill I can try and answer some
questions but I'm sure there's people
behind me that will do would do a better
job
okay so anybody have any questions
okay thank you
so next we have
Liz panterelli
thank you chair boom and committee for
allowing me to testify this morning my
name is Liz tantarelli I'm president of
the League of Women Voters of New
Hampshire a nonpartisan organization
dedicated to empowering voters and
defending democracy
campaign Finance reform has long long
long been a part of the League's work
where 103 year old organization and we
support ways in which we can
continue to have vigorous elections but
not with undue influence by any party I
have been testifying for bills to close
the LLC loophole
for at least the last five years my
testimony sites whoops sorry let me get
the right page my testimony sites bills
in 2021
and
2019 and they've had support of both the
House and Senate and it was the governor
who stymied it
if I knew better how to navigate The
Campaign Finance website I'd find out I
would like to find out how many of the
governor's campaign donations came from
LLCs and how many of those llc's
donor owners of the LLCs were also
donors in other ways
so what I did find in a November 15 2020
article in the Concord Monitor gives you
a little information on llc's at that
time and I couldn't find an update sorry
at that time there were about 65
llc's in good standing and they are the
vast majority of New Hampshire
businesses except for these sole
proprietorship businesses and at least
75 percent of them had a single owner I
do know from talking with some people
that people are in business often have
multiple llc's so not only could an
individual make a donation in his or her
own name but also in the name of
multiple llc's so the intent of this
bill is to recognize that fact and say
that Jane Smith just because she's got
several llc's cannot exceed the campaign
donations to a particular candidate by
making them from one two three llc's
plus herself and that to me seems very
very logical and I urge you to support
this
I'll take questions if there are any but
I'm not an expert on llc's Bill do we
have any questions
thank you thank you
next
is Bob Avery
oh Perry Oh that's a p I'm sorry it
looked like an a
[Laughter]
H Bob Perry town of Stratford
good morning everyone
I speak in support of HB 255
multiple legislative attempts have been
made in recent years to close what is
known as the LLC loophole
why is it a loophole
because it allows one person to make
maximum campaign contributions through
each one of his or her limited liability
companies
and why do we want to close that
loophole
because it empowers one person
who would otherwise be my equal
to make multiple contributions using
ownership of one or more llc's to
overwhelm the political influence my
contribution would have simply because
the choice was made to establish the
businesses as an LSC LLC
which has its own benefits as you just
heard but perhaps with a specific intent
in mind to take advantage of the
loophole
the focus of this bill is reduced to
single member llc's but the concept is
the same and it requires that political
contributions made by a limited
liability company be allocated to
members for purposes of determining
whether a member has exceeded the
contribution limits
there is no bar to making contributions
only that those contributions not exceed
established limits in the aggregate
no tracking of those contributions is
required by the state under this bill
tracking is done by the LLC itself
in providing the recipient with the
names and addresses of all members for
the purpose of reporting
reporting under current law only
requires the name of the LLC be
disclosed not the names of the people
behind the LLC making the contribution
I spoke with a fundraiser a year and a
half ago who said raising money for a
candidate stats by calling owners of
LLCs because a single call can generate
multiple contributions
there is no efficiency in first calling
on small donors those people
who might even be constituents
the the default position is to approach
those who have a financial advantage
over the rest
the Brennan Center for justice confirms
that over the decades quote the U.S
Supreme Court as well as lower courts
have repeatedly and consistently upheld
state and federal laws requiring
disclosures of who is spending money in
politics
end quote
and I will add that the U.S Supreme
Court came to the same conclusion in
citizens united V FEC in 2010
emphasizing their conclusion by saying
transparency is key to the maintenance
of democracy
New Hampshire came close to requiring
apportionment in 2019 when on a
bipartisan basis the New Hampshire
legislature passed
hb156 only to suffer the governor's veto
New Hampshire has another opportunity to
pass campaign Finance reform and it
begins Anew with HB 255.
I urge you to pass
or in the alternative
please retain this bill for further
consideration or refinement
thank you
thank you any questions
going nicely thank you sir thank you and
now call Olivia zinc
thank you
foreign
members of the committee for the record
my name is Olivia Zink executive
director of open democracy action and I
live in the city of Franklin and I'm
here in support of Senate bill
255. I really hope you will fix the LLC
loophole we need to reduce the influence
of money in politics so that average
voters have a voice this bill provides
transparency and accountability
this bill has been before the committee
but in a slightly different way this
this is more focused on Single member
llc's this is an important to close the
loophole
when I first started researching the LLC
loopholes the individual limit was seven
thousand dollars now due to House Bill
fifteen thousand dollars can be given by
llc's
um so I'm going to cite some examples
under the Old Law of seven thousand
dollar
um because I have more research there
um in 2010 gubernatorial candidate John
Stevens
received over a hundred thousand dollars
from 30 llc's with two addresses one in
Massachusetts and one in Connecticut so
a hundred thousand dollars of out of
state money that were trans uh traced to
the Dunkin Donut franchises there is a
great law review about the Dunkin Donut
example
um that I'm happy to share
um also on August 18 2010 the day my
daughter turned to a year old 13 llc's
gave contributions to Kevin Smith
nearly half of Kevin Smith's three
hundred and twenty four thousand dollar
contributions came from llc's at a same
address in Westborough Massachusetts
ninety nine thousand dollars came from
55 llc's again Dunkin Donuts franchises
um with
um Massachusetts address
there was also fifty five thousand
dollars of donation from 11 llc's in
Newington and Yonkers that are connected
to Planet Fitness
headquarters
um
in 2012 Kevin landergan wrote a story
um about the LLC loophole in the Nashua
Telegraph
and he cites contributions from decking
companies decking
18630509 LLC and decking Atlantic one
two one seven two zero LLC all coming
from the 82 Flanders Road in Westborough
Massachusetts so it seems like that
address has funneled a lot of money into
New Hampshire politics over the course
of uh the last decade
I do want to say that this bill the LLC
loophole I did site two uh gubernatorial
candidates that were Republican I'm
going to say that Dan feltis used this
LLC loophole and his Treasurer Ben Kelly
used three different companies to funnel
multiple money into Dan feltis's
campaign so both parties use this LLC
loophole to a circumvent campaign
Finance limits I know you have research
from your committee assistant
I have a couple additional Bill numbers
and years that this bill has introduced
in my testimony that could be added to
that research voters know that donations
um
are taken to buy influence it's pure and
simple
and we need to know who's spending money
and instead of which donors are hiding
behind llc's
um this committee has an opportunity
um to ensure that there's more
transparency
and to give voters more trust in the
process so I please urge ought to pass
and fix the LLC loophole before the next
election and with that I'm happy to take
any questions
thank you do we have any questions
representative oh representative Kennedy
thanks Mr chairman I don't know if
you're the right person to address the
text here but my question has to do with
the allocation of the contributions and
there's a sentence here that starts on
line 12 no starts online well actually
it starts on nine but it continues on
and it says a contribution made by a
domestic or foreign limited liability
company shall be attributed to its
members as if the contributions were
made by the members so I'm assuming
there's an assumption there that it's
distributed equally I guess I don't know
if you want to put you know if someone
wants to put that in there because later
on it has this is a little bit
complicated it says if a member of a
limited liability company is itself a
limited liability company the portion of
the contribution allocated to that
member which I guess is the LLC that's
in the other LLC
shall be allocated among its members on
the basis of their percentage membership
interests so there's there's nothing
like that about an LLC that's not within
another LLC so I don't know if that
could be made more clear
um I I think it could be made more clear
um thank you for your question
um we've looked at this in other states
to try to look at what other states have
for laws so this is very similar to
language in other states but I think a
good resource is the campaign Legal
Center that has all the different
languages and all the different states
but I think this bear Bill did narrow
the scope to the single member LLC
um and so it's really trying to get
after
I'll just use my mom for example my mom
has an accounting company so if the if
she makes a campaign contribution to me
if I'm running for office
she can make a personal contribution of
fifteen thousand dollars and her
business can make a fifteen thousand
dollar contribution and this bill is
basically saying no Olivia's mom can't
give her thirty thousand dollars she can
only give her fifteen thousand dollars
because my mom is a sole proprietor in
her accounting business but there are
some llc's
the Dunkin Donuts franchises are are
some of them some of them are owned by
different people and some of them are
owned by the same people so it's really
trying to get and some llc's are
actually owned by another LLC so the
language you pointed to was trying to
get back to the person
who's the member
um and so I I understand that it's a
little confusing but really what it's
trying to do is say if you take money
from this entity you just have to find
out who you're taking money from so that
they can't use this limit I mean
basically what people are doing is
funneling large sums of money
using multiple vehicles and they can
still do that by creating a pack doesn't
hurt you know any of Dunkin Donuts
franchise could create a pack and still
funnel lots of money into elections this
doesn't prevent them but it just doesn't
it doesn't allow business owners to do
this through their LLCs
uh
I'll be brief um yeah it's very clear in
terms of a single member LLC and you
know I understand the idea of an LLC in
an LLC but in that case there's some
wording about percentages and that's not
the case you know above where they're
just talking about an LLC so even though
it's focused on single members it does
discuss llc's in general so we could
look at the language
um in last year's bill which was uh
Senate bill to
48 which had the percentages in there so
if we wanted to pull the language from
last year we we tried to narrow this to
the single member llc's uh because we
knew that trying to get everybody was
was hard so we were trying to you know
scale it back a little bit but if if you
want that language of the percentages
um that language is is in a previous
draft of this
have they oh that's the second question
sorry
um so I have some research back at my
office on which other states have LLC
loopholes there are some states that
have complete and total corporate banned
um so in the states that have uh 100
corporate banned there's no LLC loophole
legislation but there is I can email you
which other states have similar
legislation who've closed the LLC
loopholes in their states
uh could you also send us if if it's
there have they been tested in court
because as I recall there was some
concern in years past that this may not
be that this would not be constitutional
and my understanding is it has passed
but if you can get us those yeah I know
that they've been challenged at least
one other state has challenged the a law
like this and it has
um stood up that the transparency and
disclosure is an important measure
um so there has been laws in other
states and they have been challenged by
the courts and withhold withheld those
challenges and I'm happy to try to pull
that or I can go back to the campaign
Legal Center and get them to pull those
Court race uh Corp
Court um dockets for you
thank you any any further questions
with that thank you and representative
wood could you get the blue sheet for us
please
and anybody else want to speak I think
we've heard everybody here and I'm
wondering if you could
look up online
signed in a port electronically yeah
yeah for you and it's blank
okay and let's we'll chat so with that
and we'll close the hearing on two five
five and we got six minutes before our
next hearing on 402.
Mr chair
online there are 75 people who have
signed in in support two who have signed
in in opposition
thank you representative Brennan
thank you
let's continue on with uh House Bill 402
and I recognize this prime prime sponsor
representative Heinz
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Dan Hines
representing the town of Alfred and this
bill I believe is an election Integrity
bill so the main thing this bill is it
would essentially put specific penalties
um on essentially defamation against
um political candidates and this bill is
limited um in the sense that it doesn't
apply to reporters Media or just the
average person it specifically is
applying to candidates
um political committees or political
parties and the reason for that is I
think those people have more of a
essentially Duty not to lie against
candidates so this essentially is a
defamation bill because candidates are
public officials they're um when they
want to bring a defamation complaint
it's a higher standard so it's not the
typical negligence so in a regular
defamation case if someone's not a
public figure essentially truth is
always a defense but other than that the
store the Court's just going to apply a
negligent standard so if someone just
accidentally lies about someone they
could be held liable for a non-public
official but when it's public official
um the Supreme Court has decided that
there's certain additional protections
that needed to be given to those people
um so one of the things is they can only
recover if they show its knowing which
makes sense people should not knowingly
be able to lie against
um and to fame people and then kind of
in them claim a privilege and the other
is if they act in Reckless or act with
actual malice which generally is a
reckless disregard for the truth so it's
higher than a negligent standard but
less than a knowing standard and I think
the reason this bill is needed is
particularly last election cycle there
were numerous pacts that were on both
sides that we're making and just
blatantly wrong Incorrect
characterizations and lying about either
candidates records or their position on
bills and I think that's wrong I think
that misleads people and I think it's
particularly air when it's a huge pack
spends all this money and that the
candidate often cannot properly respond
so one of those things I want the bill
does is it's essentially a notice
requirement and I do have a typo in the
bill so it would need an amendment uh
the type was on line six
um the last word
um so it reads false statements issued
on the home page of a candidate
political committee or political parts
website is evidence of their position on
an issue and Prima flash evidence of
Reckless disregard the truth so the word
false isn't supposed to be there and so
what that meant was
um I think pretty much most candidates
can have a website or very easily can
cheaply have a website so on the website
if a candidate's listing his specific
position that I don't think a pack
should be able to come in and just claim
the complete opposite this wouldn't go
to opinion so obviously people are
entitled to their opinion assigned
issues it's specifically
um is when people are just lying about
mechanics position on an issue or
otherwise is harming the reasonably
harming the candidate's reputation which
is a defamation standard as well
um and then the final thing the bill
does is just codifies different
um penalties for various types of
deformation and
uh I'm happy to take any questions
representative Kennedy
thanks Mr chairman uh thanks for taking
my question I'm just wondering who would
adjudicate whether something is a lie or
not nope uh Jerry
any other question remember Jim Howard
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question uh how is current uh
defamation law not currently addressing
this issue
uh two ways um so our present defamation
law doesn't have any specific penalties
with it uh certain day the jury yes
could reasonably import a point award
someone the damages that they incurred
um but this bill specifically made
specific damages so a jury doesn't have
to guess at the sorry guess at the harm
um someone caused and I think that would
hopefully deter people from acting in
that manner and the other way is
um with the assuming the typo is fixed
um that it allows someone to respond on
their website and I believe legislature
can properly say well we're gonna find
that that in itself is reckless
disregard if you if a candidate has on
their website so presently a candidate
can put their position on a website but
I could see in a point saying well I
didn't check that so I didn't know it
was wrong so I think this sort of just
puts an extra Duty on someone if they're
going to make representations about a
candidate
okay
any other representative program thank
you Mr chairman
are you aware of any other uh
jurisdiction that does this political uh
subdivision that does this at this point
in other states I am not um so I tried
to follow or just build on our
defamation law
um and then just incorporate various
protections that Supreme Court has
awarded to defamation um so I I am not
aware of that
any other questions
so thank you thank you
anybody else want to testify on this
with that uh representative wood could
nine
see the blue sheet blades
you and nearly write only 23 minutes
and another blank
and represent Brennan do you do homework
again
all right
okay
opposed nine neutral one okay
thank you and and now we have a like a
22 minute uh break before our next bill
which will be hb463.
wait
thank you
okay
foreign
thank you
this is
yep
foreign
let me know
prototype
tonight
thank you
oh yeah
foreign
thank you
bye
guys
good morning committee good morning Mr
chair thanks for allowing me the
opportunity to introduce HB 463
um
this is a pretty straightforward Bill
the concept's been in front of the this
committee uh before
um I'm not gonna
sort of go into great detail other than
to note that it's creating
um an election portal
for folks to do a couple of things
related to registering to vote and
basically it creates a hub for
um
potential voters and registrants to
access and provide information
I don't want to bury the lead here but
I'm going to respectfully suggest that
maybe the committee retain the bill I'll
talk about the merits of the bill only
for the purpose because there's another
bill that Senator gray has championed
and will come before this committee that
is is probably a better bill in my in my
view
um
and so I think it might
in the interest of efficiency which
we're not typically accused of here in
the legislature it might make sense to
to retain this bill and and
um and manage a Senator Senator Grace
sb70 which is coming before the
committe's gone through the Senate
um
and Senate Senate Bill 70 yeah
you know I I will sort of speak briefly
to the merits again in the interest of
efficiency but um this is a concept of
modernizing the Secretary of State's
office where I think there are a great
majority of states have something
similar to this uh including Maine I
believe in terms of being
allowing folks to have the ability to
entertain to input information relevant
information
for registering to vote this bill 463
relates to two groups in particular uh
people who who have particular barriers
to registering to vote people in active
military service and people with
disabilities
um
one of the reasons I think that this
Senator Grace bill is is probably better
is that it does it's a bit more
expansive at the same same cost as this
one um
I think from the perspective of uh uh
administratively at the local level this
is something that will ultimately
relieve burdens for local clerks and
supervisors of the checklist there are
some numbers out there that um
quantify how much money it costs for a
clerk to register a vote this is Pennies
on the dollar in terms of that to save
and allows are already strapped local
government agencies to focus on other
things
um
one issue this bill as I mentioned this
concept has come before this committee
and other
forms one particular issue had been
caused the the number that had been
associated with prior construction of an
information portal is significantly
lower this time around
than it has been in the past
I don't need to probably elaborate but I
certainly can in terms of
the groups that are mentioned in this
bill that would
benefit from having a reduction in the
barriers and the transactions cost
transaction transaction costs and being
able to register to vote but as I said
you know I don't want to bury the lead
here I think it might be in the interest
of the committee and to to retain the
bill it's awkward for me to say that but
um I think the other bill that's coming
through might be the one that deserves
the committee's
more more attention so but I'm happy to
take questions
um from folks thank you are there any
questions
with that thank you thank you for
hearing my testimony no I now call
deputy secretary of state Aaron Herron
Hennessey
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee I am Aaron Hennessey deputy
secretary of state good morning I wanted
to let you all know that we do support
this bill with one slight Amendment and
that Amendment would be to remove the
Restriction
um to two types of New Hampshire
citizens to open it up to all New
Hampshire citizens and that is in line
with what the Senate has already passed
and that would be as the sponsor said SB
70. the important information in this
portal is it the important thing about
it is that it makes it easy for New
Hampshire residents to change their
registration to um to actually register
but also keeps in line with our our laws
in New Hampshire and to make sure that
the information goes to the appropriate
elected official for example if you're
requesting an absentee ballot that would
go to the clerk if you're requesting
updates or to register
um that would go to the supervisors of a
checklist I'm happy to take questions
but I do know know that the sponsor has
asked you to retain this and that sb70
would be coming before you when
crossover happens
thank you yes represent wood thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question
um on authenticating the person behind
the portal what are your thoughts about
problems or Solutions on that
the um the portal will be designed to
collect all the information that needs
to be collected when you register to
vote in the first place so anything that
you would require to present you would
have to present in digital format so a
copy of or a scanned picture of whatever
identity that you would have or proof of
residence or proof of citizenship
does that answer your question
okay it does
follow-up yes so we we hear uh quite
often that this information is hard to
come by for the people who are walking
in
um how do you think that's going to fly
with a portal
the
I don't know that this restricts applic
people registering to vote to the portal
I'd have to look into that but I think
there would still be the walk-in option
for people is that what you were is that
was that your question yes thank you
thank you
any other questions
oh I got one
doesn't show a cost how much you think
this will cost Secretary of State
so our estimation is that
um the cost would be approximately
477 dollars in the first year and that
is all of the design work
um most most of that would be it work to
implement the portal any training that
needs to be done
um individuals that we would need to
hire a lot of the the work that would be
done locally would now be shifted to
phone calls and questions and answers at
the Secretary of State's office so we've
had a lot of discussions with the
sponsor of the Senate bill that there
would possibly need somebody additional
staffing needs and Secretary of State's
office so you repeat that cost again oh
sorry
477 dollars in in 2024 and you should
have a fiscal note on this does yours
not have a fiscal note yeah but it's
empty oh I think what happened perhaps
what happened was it was added after
your bills were printed if you go to the
online version it's on there so okay 47
77 in the first year and then and then
in the following years uh would be
at least I'm trying to look at each
individual cost
um
at least 77 000 but up to 274
000. if you have to hire somebody yeah
okay so thank you any other questions
thank you I just want to clarify it is
on sb70 so if you oh look up sb70 all
the financial stuff is there okay okay
it's it should Mr chair it should be on
your the HB 463 as well okay or at least
it is on my version okay
okay thank you thank you
okay now next is
Liz tantarelli
ready to call her again
foreign
thank you Mr chair for this opportunity
to speak on HB 463 I do have written
testimony that's being passed around my
name is Liz tentarelli I'm speaking
today as president of the League of
Women Voters of New Hampshire
where empowering voters by creating
opportunities to register that are not
rooted in the 17th century by going to
the town clerk's office makes sense
uh so my my testimony refers to the fact
that there are at as far as I could find
only eight states that do not allow any
part of the registration process online
and so we would be coming into the 21st
century and that's kind of a nice place
to live
so I do support this bill I support SB
70 even stronger because it it applies
to everyone
and I was very happy to hear that the
sponsor suggests this bill be retained
in favor of sb70 when it comes along
but even just this bill does allow for
two groups that have particularly tough
times getting to the town clerk's office
to be able to make changes to
registration and to do their
registration process online
so for active military it's a no-brainer
they may not be around for months and
months at a time
and for people with disabilities getting
to the town clerk's office may be a
serious problem
so I certainly support this bill I've
been testifying in favor of this for at
least three years and I urge the
committee to First retain it and then
look very favorably on its cousin SB 70
when that comes along I'd be glad to
take questions if there are any
thank you any questions
good thank you for the opportunity
I'm
call
Mackenzie Saint-Germain Mackenzie Saint
Germain
um
good morning members of the committee my
name is Mackenzie St Germain I'm the
campaign director for the New Hampshire
campaign for voting rights and I'm
representing New Hampshire campaign for
voting rights and America votes New
Hampshire
um we as a coalition support any
um bill or that creates an election
information portal um as other mentioned
a robust portal like sb70 these bills
would uh both benefit our election
officials and voters by allowing voters
to complete a new voter application
register
um to over the first time request an
absentee ballot make updates to their
voter registration quickly and easily
online many people these days are very
comfortable registering their car online
paying their bills and it just makes
sense at this point in time for us to
also give voters that option to manage
their voter registration information
online as well and with the ease of
being able to have voters complete an
application ahead of time ahead of going
to the polls we can also reduce the
number of Voters who are registering for
the first time on Election Day reducing
the number of Voters who maybe forget a
document and have to register with an
affidavit or people you know waiting in
long lines to register on Election Day
because they weren't able to get to
their clerk's office ahead of time but
would be able to register online you
know after work from home and this also
would help voters update their
information more quickly than currently
happens with addresses keeping our voter
rolls more updated and clean which is
something that we know can increase
voter confidence when those are more up
to date
this would also support our supervisors
with a checklist cutting back on the
amount of data entry they have also the
difficulty in Reading handwriting or
reading people's names but I know my
handwriting is not always the cleanest
or clearest and can reduce some of those
potential errors in data entry and
copying over names and addresses that
can cause issues or confusion in our
voter roles so as you move forward with
this process looking at this bill in
sb70 I really want to just emphasize the
importance and the support from the New
Hampshire campaign for voting rights for
establishing a portal
no I'm happy to take any questions thank
you anybody have any questions
thank you
I now call
Sarah lovedell
well correct me if I pronounce that
all right good morning uh my name is
Sarah Lobdell I'm a voter in Keene and
program coordinator of open democracy
we're a nonpartisan non-profit Pro voter
organization with over 36 000 members
and I am speaking this morning in
support of HB 463
so on this day March 7th today in 1965
hundreds of black and brown voters uh
Marchers walked across the Pettus bridge
in Selma Alabama peacefully demanding
and equal right to vote these Marchers
were met with violence walking to make
the ballot equally accessible for all
and HB 463 and its cousin HP 70 are an
extension of this Legacy that take a
step towards making the ballot equally
accessible for all
much of what I had in my written
testimony has already been said so I
would just add that
um
uh reductions in the cost of Staff time
was brought up in terms of
um what it cost to process a paper
registration form and in my testimony
there's analysis of that and an average
cost would be
4.72 cents in staff time for every paper
registration process so that is a
potential cost saving to towns and
cities
um and yeah I would Echo what has
already been said and would encourage
you to look favorably on sb70 when it
comes your way and to wrap up on the
online portal for this bill 80 people
have signed it in support and 60 are in
opposition last I checked earlier this
morning
thank you anybody have any questions
but that thank you
um representative wood
blue sheet unless anybody else wants to
speak
and uh
lest they spoke oh
one person four
two big Olivia didn't speak okay two
people four nobody against
so with that I'm gonna close the hearing
on
463 and we have
12 minutes before our next bill which is
476.
foreign
on House Bill 476 enabling the SEC
Secretary of State to conduct a second
recount after an election
and and representatives Sweeney is going
to represent the Bill thank you thank
you so much Mr chairman members of the
House election law committee uh for the
record representative Joe Sweeney from
Rockingham District 25 comprising the
town of Salem uh how proud to introduce
House Bill 476 today enabling the
Secretary of State to conduct a second
recount after an election uh election
laws Vice chair representative Berry is
the prime sponsor cannot be here today
um essentially what this bill uh seeks
to do in the intent of the bill when it
was filed is we had a rather notorious
case of a recount back in November in
which the recount resulted initially in
a change in the election results but it
was it was clear from calculations that
the number of ballots did not match up
from that first recount to the election
night and then a subsequent audit of
that Ward race uh further confirmed
there was a difference in the number of
ballots counted it or counted in that
race then of course cast which led to a
a really unprecedented but necessary
second recount of Ward 6 which then
later confirmed the initial election
Night results
and got rid of the disparity between the
counts of the ballots as written and
I've talked to the sponsor about this
and I know the sponsor has has talked to
members of on both sides of the election
law committee prior to this hearing
about fixing this bill as we're in this
bill simply gives the Secretary of State
the discretion to order a second recount
if necessary
we feel that that is uh an unnecessary
power to any state employee any any
state officer and even the Secretary of
State and I know that the sponsor is
working with members of this committee
uh one who's not here today as well on
figuring out the mechanism for how to
make this a clear and transparent system
where if there is an issue found after
the first recount that a second recount
would be ordered automatically
regardless of the discretion of the
Secretary of State being used I'm not
privy to what those conversations are
but I do know that they are happening
between members on this committee I'm
happy to answer any questions but I'm
not sure what the uh the end result will
be but I believe it would be something
similar to if a audit of the race shows
a different number of ballots cast than
what the recount showed then there would
be uh grounds for a second recount
automatically and not at the discretion
but am happy to take any questions the
community members may have thank you do
we have any questions
with that thank you oh yes
representative
um what if an audit showed in the second
recount a discrepancy would that justify
a third recount
that is a phenomenal question and I do
know that the sponsors we do not want to
see Recon after recount after recount
um so that would have to be buttoned up
in terms of the policies that what is
the what is the you know acceptable what
have what happens if there keeps being a
variance if there's a variance from
election night to the second recount to
the audit to the third recount or sorry
first recount to the audit to the second
recount uh I'm not sure what we would do
and I'm not sure what we would need to
put in the safeguards in the policy in
the legislation to prevent that
okay I have a follow-up Please Mr chair
thank you
um I'm thinking you know with respect to
buttoning up this bill
um
that there may be two broad Avenues one
is to specify the kinds of reasons that
would justify a second recount that's
what I think we're just talking about
and the other is to design a process
that gives the public confidence that
the secretary of state had good reason
whatever the reason might have been and
I can imagine that the legislation might
require well let me rephrase please
would you
possibly support legislation that
required the Secretary of State to do
something like make the reasons explicit
to maybe the state supreme court
before a second recount could proceed
so so thank you for the question I would
not be opposed to making sure there are
strong safeguards in here to make sure
that the policy isn't uh open to abuse
or to discretion
um and I know that the the lack of dis
limiting the amount of discretion in the
process is the goal of fixing this this
piece of legislation as it is introduced
I won't speak for the prime sponsor
because you know eight times out of ten
who knows
um but I think he's based on the
conversation I had with him yesterday I
think he's of the same vein of thought
representative wood
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh the bill currently says
specifically that the Secretary of State
makes this call so in your testimony you
said it's something slightly different
uh
can you clear that clarify please
absolutely the the bill as introduced
just gives the Secretary of State the
con the discretion to conduct a second
recount if for for whatever reason
there's a discrepancy found
while that's the way the bill has been
introduced there is an effort to button
up that policy and that procedure to
make it based on clear metrics that are
transparent to so it's it doesn't matter
on which case it's just if it hits the
threshold for discrepancy or whatnot and
I and again I'm not privy to those
conversations that representative
Barry's having but I do know that they
are working on building together the
sort of framework for what would what
would necessitate a second recount
thank you any other questions okay thank
you sweetie thank you very much
I now call Representative gagne
good morning all
Mr chairman for the record my name is
Larry gagne I'm a state representative
from Hillsborough District 16 which is
Ward 6 in Manchester
I'm The Man Behind the reason why
uh this bill is before us
um this first I hear about them wanting
to tweak it and and change different
things I'm not blaming any anyone for
anything here my my thoughts is that
there was
you know how the recounts go this the
stacks of ballots there was chaos in
there there were three or four different
recounts going on and people were 25 50
like I said I'm not blaming anyone I'm
thinking that what happened was there
was a stack of ballots that were
miscounted
what they did
is when we won the case in Merrimack
Superior Court
that the recount before they counted
names they counted the totality of the
ballots on hand compared it to the
totality of the pallet ballots on
Election night and they had found out
that there was a discrepancy
on a recount we had fewer ballots
so now they started the recount after
the count was correct and I ended up
winning
thank God
but I'm here specifically
um my wife and I held hands the first
time for six and a half hours the next
time for about six seven and a half
seven hours and I'm an old man
and I don't want anyone else to go
through this that we went through uh I
hadn't been in Superior Court since I
was a cop way back in the 70s so I
didn't like that so that's why I'm here
and I'm hoping that this committee can
tweak it it's first I hear this morning
that uh
representative Sweeney that they were
working you were working on tweaking
this some so this does not happen again
for either side
thank you we have any questions
with that
thank you
and uh represent what could you check
the blue sheet please
and doesn't look like we have any more
pink sheets
and nobody else wants to talk
so
we can have an early lunch
and could you I just went flying
thank you
and another blank boost sheet
so with that and close the hearing of
and we have at one o'clock is uh 478 so
with that
breaking for lunch
Back At One thank you
thank you Mr chair
okay welcome back we're a little late uh
but anyway
our next bill
is HB 478 relative to ballot order in
the general election and representative
wood is going to introduce it because
this is representing Barry's Bill and
he's not here so
thank you Mr chair I'd like to introduce
Bill HB 478 to the house floor for
public session uh this bill makes
changes to the creation of the ballot
order in the general election
so is there anybody that wants to speak
on this
if not I guess we can
right I mean if somebody wants to
yeah
oops
I mean you can
sorry uh thank you Mr chairman one thing
I did notice was like on line 25 I guess
it's only one page
candidates for the office of state
representative who did not run in a
primary but are eligible to peer of the
general ballot shall be listed similarly
with the person receiving the most
signatures to appear on the ballot
receiving the first position I mean in
my case
um I didn't run in a primary and I
didn't get any signatures either so I'm
not sure what that means
really give me a good answer
discussing 478 there's nobody to speak
on it and representative wood broad you
know introduced it but
basically we can just take comments if
anybody's got one and then
yes it doesn't happen Okay well to
answer representative Kennedy's question
might
only thought is that I had an
independent opposing me so he didn't run
in the primary
and this would say I don't know what the
rule is now but it would just say his
name would be
uh appear on the general ballot she'll
be listed similarly with the
you know the other people that
that won first place in their primary
is he was an independent independent so
we didn't have to run in a primary
I don't know
foreign
just trying to understand the logic but
my understanding of this bill is that
right now there's a random order that a
random selection that governs the you
know order of names and the general
election ballot and on the primary
ballot instead of that we'll do a random
order for the primary but we'll take the
number of votes in the primary to
determine the order in the general
election ballot and what I noticed is
that
um
in multi-candidate primaries
the primary ballot name order often
decides who gets the most votes I just
see a lot of people voting for the first
candidate and then a number of votes
tapering off as you go down the list so
it seems to just reward the random
chance that you got listed first in the
primary ballot by giving you the first
position on the general election ballot
I'm not sure what I you know what the
logic of that is
yeah I mean
can considering that there could be a
presidential primary for instance on one
side of the ballot uh that could
drastically influence how many people
actually show up and vote so there could
be one side that ends up getting a huge
turnout rate that otherwise would be in
the minority potentially in any given
District
yeah some notice when
over the years when they first came I
think of 2005 2006 when they change it
to be random order the candidate used to
be alphabetical
and the argument then was a a B's and
C's and would always win which wasn't
and when I first got here I was in the
middle of the first page
now I'm the bottom of the second page so
that the alphabetical order didn't work
you know so I don't know I think it's
the way it is now I think it works fine
but the only problem I didn't really
like was last year when they changed for
the
column rotations it's back back way up
to the Senate District and they picked
the Senate District and then that goes
for the whole Senate District which in
like in Litchfield it's five Wards in
Manchester and let that six six places
where the order's the same and used to
being different but anyway I don't know
but anyway
yes representative
I'm just going to comment that uh I
believe the order of uh the candidates
in the ballot does not necessarily
decide who wins however if they're close
like I was in a primary with four
candidates for for three positions but
whoever is the first will have about two
percent that's just a statistical
observation that's that's a well-known
um in well-known studies and uh that
could certainly uh change like for uh if
you're selecting three out of four it
can change the the two depending on
Whose uh who's first yeah I think the
more people running it's more or less
you further down the list you get
ignored but I mean but if there's only a
couple people do three I mean I don't
think it really mattered that much but
anyway so we have 20 minutes before our
next bill and maybe we'll have somebody
else come
here
what oh yeah there's probably nothing on
it but
[Music]
what's the document
Ary
that somehow is an executive session
I'm asking is
Amendment oh yeah that was one of the
problems is
and we'll have a blank blue sheet so
then I'll close the hearing on
or
yeah he'd have to take his kid to the
hospital
what bill was this
478.
and we're in recess till 1 30.
now I turn the light on
thank you uh thank you uh Mr chairman
um and uh members of the election law
committee uh I apologize for the way I'm
dressed I thought I would have time to
change after my EKG uh the good news is
my heart is fine I'm and more
importantly I don't think I'm contagious
with anything so
um so
496 uh it was born out of a conversation
I I had in Auburn uh door knocking a few
years ago
and the uh the Jacobs are here today but
while I was door knocking they shared
with me
um a story that uh really generated a
lot of angst during the conversation
about how their mother had been
was a resident in a nursing home and
they that they stumbled upon the
children stumbled upon the fact that she
had registered to get receive an
absentee ballot and she cast it
and the her mom their mom was not in any
position mentally she had Dementia or
something I don't know how much they
want to talk about that but
um and so I think their perception was
that this was a form of elder abuse to
be able to go in and register people to
vote and cast an absentee ballot for
them when
there's very little
cognizance about what is going on and if
you go through our nursing homes in this
state you'll find an extremely high
percentage of people with dementia even
up like in the veterans home they have
half of the beds basically set aside for
dementia patients and the other half are
supposed to be non-dementia patients and
even in the non-devention award
um 60 70 percent of those are have
dementia so
so I think this this bill attempts to
say that it's absolutely vital that we
protect a person's right to vote and
their dignity to cast their vote and
while at the same time acknowledging
that the way in which we manage their
ballots
may be appropriate for us to ensure that
they have some capacity to request and
cast a ballot and and so
even though they told me this their
their story about three years ago I
missed last election cycle because
working with the representative Griffin
we couldn't figure out how to approach
the bill so this time around I just went
to
um
um Dave Scanlon when when he was the uh
deputy secretary of state and this is
essentially his language this is what he
came up with after about eight months of
thinking about it how we might do it
um and I I think that uh it's a it's a
really great first attempt to to have
the conversation about what could be or
should be and what should not be done in
this area
and and uh and if there's a a way for us
to to to say yes to each other and to
figure out a way to pass some
protections while fully preserving the
right to vote I I think that would be a
great outcome I don't think it's an easy
balance but but I think we owe it to
ourselves to have that conversation uh
the Secretary of State's office is
represented here certainly the Jacob
ribs are here they're in favor I believe
the the town clerks are not in favor
um and and I can kind of understand that
there's more work here than what we've
done in the past and I don't know what
the other objections are I would hope
that they would share the the goal of
trying to prevent elder abuse and voter
theft but
um I'll I'll take questions if there are
any
thank you do any questions
representative
thank you Mr chair
um
my understanding of this bill from line
7 to 10 is that
the absentee ballot observers who are
representatives of the two parties that
receive the highest number of votes in
the last election
ensure that
the process of receiving marketing
returning apps debalance is fair private
and properly handled what would happen
if
uh the two ballot observers disagreed
with each other about whether the
process was Fair private and properly
handled I I think I I think that's a
good question to expand on details
within the bill and maybe the deputy
secretary of state may have some ideas
on that I'm not steeped in election law
but what I I think might be able to
happen is is that the the you know there
there could be a contested ballot and
there we do have some procedures I
understand for uh contesting ballots and
and
reconciling perspectives before their
cast
but but I don't know the real answer
follow-up thank you
um does this bill mean that no one in a
nursing home may fill out an absentee
ballot unless the two absentee ballot
observers are present in the facility
I I don't know that that would be a good
outcome I don't think that would be a
good outcome and if you think the
legislation says that then I'd be happy
to see alternative language certainly
just because you're in a nursing home
doesn't mean you're incapacitated uh the
odds of it go up dramatically based on
the statistics but but uh I you know my
my first principle is that we must first
protect the right to vote
and then beyond that the issue gets to
be is are there reasonable things we can
do to mitigate the potential for
somebody
falsifying the absentee ballot process
and casting a ballot without the
awareness of the actual voter and you'll
listen to the Jacobs and they have an
extremely well documented case of one
such example of what I I think it's
elder abuse but
foreign
thank you
um
thank you I appreciate your explanation
so
my understanding is that the two ballot
observers would accompany the town clerk
as the absentee ballots are delivered to
the facility but would not be in the
facility then when the ballots are being
marked
um
or returned and collected
and so my question is how could those
observers then attest that the process
is
fair if they're not in the building when
the ballots are being marked and when
the ballots are being collected but are
only present when the ballots are being
delivered by the hand by the town clerk
I I I I can see where you would make
that assumption I I don't know if I join
you in that assumption I'm reading line
seven eight nine uh the absentee ballot
observers shall ensure the process of
receiving marking and returning the
absentee ballots is fair private and
properly handled and so
um you know it I I think there may be
some Unwritten words here on how they
would ensure that but the scope of this
is meant to include the entire workflow
of Distributing and and collecting the
ballots
represent Kennedy yeah this this is kind
of a follow-up to representative Muir
has question because if you deliver the
ballot uh the person has to think about
what they're doing right I mean unless
there's some procedure to make sure
they've looked at a sample ballot or
whatever so would The Observers simply
have to stay there on site until the
ballots are marked and collected
I I don't I don't know what that
procedure would look like uh this this
is uh the first year that this bill has
been proposed and it was written in
isolation by uh
Secretary of State Scanlon and you know
I trust I trust the legislative process
I trust this committee to basically
think through some of these details that
maybe were not thought of you know late
night at his desk when he was typing
this up so
um
okay
any other questions
representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
so um if uh so in a nursing home in a
big nursing home when um is this
something that will be like an event
like okay all of the requests have to be
done at the same time for residents of
the nursing home such that when uh
they're delivered they're delivered at
the same time so that the people who are
accompanying the ballots and the
markings and all of that will be done as
kind of like an event in that nursing
home or is this something that's done
upon request such that each resident May
request it at a different time so they
get delivered marked submitted and then
another Resident may do it at another
time I'm just trying to picture how how
this unfolds I I don't I don't know what
that would look like I I know having
visited nursing homes when my
mother-in-law was in them the nursing
director was desperate to find events so
if there was a can at night if there was
a you know ballot night uh I I I don't I
don't think there's anything in here
that would preclude that or require it
thank you
any more questions
representative Brennan thank you and
thank you for taking my question this
kind of follows up to what
representative Bay was talking about so
it's my understanding that when someone
wants to fill out an absentee ballot
they first have to go through the
absentee ballot request form
um I don't see anything in this bill
here and I'm wondering if it is your
intent that
the absentee ballot observers that there
would be observers during the request
process as well
because if we're talk I'm trying to
understand if the concern is that an
individual does not have the capacity to
fill out an absentee ballot
would they not also
would there also be a concern about them
being able to properly or adequately
fill out an absentee ballot request form
in my experience with dementia patients
in nursing homes
yeah somebody with dementia is going to
have a really hard time even making a
proper respect or request for an
absentee ballot and uh and what we end
up doing to basically assist that
without uh replacing their independent
judgment I I don't know this I think
this is a very difficult issue and I
hope whatever we do we come down on the
side of protecting the right to vote but
I I really would just like to see us
think through how we might be able to
also protect our seniors that really are
no longer able to participate in the
electoral process
and not have their ballots abused
follow please
are you aware of this being a
sizable significant
issue or is this a one-time couple of
time occurrences that there has been an
issue that has raised concerns for the
family of the
uh elderly Nursing Home Patient
so there are no statistics that I know
of on that and and uh and talking uh
with uh Miss Hennessy from the Secretary
of State's office before the hearing
um we don't have any data even to say
what number of absentee ballots are
requested by residents in nursing homes
there's a lack of data here they just
they they know how many absentee ballots
we have but they don't keep track of
where the request was originated so we
don't really have that data we have one
very clear example in one nursing home
in New Hampshire where I think it's
inarguable that there was abuse and is
one enough well I think
one
causes us to step back and say did this
one expose something that we should be
concerned about systemically if if if
the one happened in one nursing home a
that suggests that a person was working
the system to go get other
um
patients ballots from that same nursing
home so so even though we just have we
know one it kind of suggests you know
maybe it would have been worth an
investigation to go see if this happened
on that election at that nursing home
other times but but no such request was
made that I know of
one more follow-up okay um last because
we need to move on yes thank you
appreciate it
um
is because you seem to have a knowledge
of um nursing homes I just is there a
process by which a family member of a
resident of a nursing home would be able
to make a request of that nursing home
that they do not provide that nursing
home resident with an absentee ballot
request form I I think that's a really
great question to ask the the children
of the mom that that went through this
they they held a a power of attorney for
them the mom and and generally what the
power of attorney does is it basically
delegates to somebody to make major
decisions for them and
um and and that power of attorney was
well known to the nursing home but no
one from the nursing home consulted with
them to determine if the request for the
absentee ballot was something that they
should check with them or not and and
certain not when the ballot was cast so
so
um
it may be an area that that our laws are
silent and and maybe that's what comes
of this and uh another term or two that
we really work through this
thank you
okay thank you and uh now
um representative prude home O'Brien
thank you
my mother-in-law was a really smart
woman and she lived with me for 17 years
and I brought her to vote
every election
until she started to be unable to pay
attention to the news
she just knew that she didn't want to
vote anymore after that and so I didn't
push it but if I did want to push it I
could have easily done so I could have
put papers in front of her and said you
have to sign this you have to do this
because sometimes I did have to put
papers in front of her and ask her a
person
signatures and she had a lot of trouble
understanding what I was I was doing but
it was really necessary whenever I did
that it was very necessary and I tried
to do it in front of my sister-in-law so
the whole family knew that
we're all on the same page with
everything that we're doing so that we
were all confident about that
and um
I don't think we have all the answers to
some of the excellent questions that
were asked right now but I think we're
this is a work in progress because these
are issues that aren't addressed
currently
but if we get started on this I think
that is the only way to to find out some
of the answers to those questions and to
move forward further legislation is
needed I I know when we when um ballots
are transferred from a polling location
to a different area
there has to be a members of two members
of different parties in the vehicle when
that's done and that makes people feel
much more confident and this is the same
thing
my mother-in-law didn't spend much time
in a nursing home in fact when she got
there she passed away soon after just
within hours
but I spent a long time just prior to
that looking for a nursing home for her
to be to be placed in because she needed
that covet hit
complicating everything but when I went
to the different nursing homes I had a
similar bill that year and it was also
near election and the people that I
spoke to at the nursing homes were
relieved the the general sense was oh
good there'll be a time when we can go
to the activities room and have this
taken care of with some people that can
answer some questions and the same thing
that I felt when I had to have my
mother-in-law sign some important
paperwork when I wanted to have as many
family members in the room when that
happened so everybody was aware of what
was going on that's how the people that
work at nursing homes would feel they
would feel like okay we had the
Republican rep we had the Democrat we
had lots of people in the room observing
and watching what was going on they felt
more confident that everybody would know
that that everything was on the up and
up and they'd feel good about it so I
think this is positive and it goes in a
good direction not just for the people
in the nursing home but
family members of of people in nursing
homes
okay thank you any quick questions
thank you
now maybe to answer some of these
questions is call up deputy secretary of
state Aaron Harris Anderson
thank you Mr chairman Aaron Hennessey
deputy secretary of state I wanted to
let everyone know okay what did I say
that oh no but I'm supposed to say it
too okay sorry
uh I wanted to let everyone know that
our office is in support of this
legislation as this of the Prime sponsor
mentioned my boss secretary Scanlon did
help him write the verbiage for this
bill
um during every election season our
office does get many many phone calls
related to nursing home and voting in
nursing home most of its complaints that
we get we see this as a good step in the
right direction and a fair process some
of the issues that come up with voting
in nursing homes is that you probably
are aware that if you hopefully it
doesn't happen but when you go into a
nursing home at some point and it's in a
different town that you do not have to
register to vote in that new town that
you can keep your old registration and
vote in in your in the town that you
were previously residing in but a lot of
nursing home residents don't know that
information and sometimes that
information is not provided to them when
someone comes and gets them to register
to vote in the new location
to answer some of Representative
Brennan's questions which are very good
to my knowledge a lot of times the
registration process
the application for an absentee ballot
process and the voting process is all
done at the same time in in the nursing
home so there doesn't have to be a lot
of back and forth
um so so
um a town clerk could come in with all
of the forms necessary and those would
be compiled just as if you were absentee
voting from from your home
to representative Bay's question about
um
and I believe it was your question about
if this would happen
um how it would happen if somebody
requested an absentee ballot
individually this would just apply to
multiple
um absentee ballots and not if you were
if you chose to request an absent seed
ballot not with the group process
um
um I just want to make make a point that
this this process the way it's written
here would make sure that everything is
transparent and would cut down I believe
on issues that people have with the the
current process and that if there were
issues the bill says that they would
contact the Secretary of State's office
but any
um enforcement would also be contacting
the AG's office
I'm happy to take questions
any questions
okay
oh representing day and
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
would something like this uh be also
pertinent to
um
poems with a mentally disabled adults or
something like that
that's a good question I think
the language just relates to nursing
home and Elder Care Facilities
so I would have to look up the
definition of what a nursing home is
thank you
great question
oh representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um I'm just curious that
um see the
resident in the nursing home is
incapable but yet is in this group
setting to vote is unaware of the
process or who like do these advisors
will will they like recommend for them
not to vote do they have that ability
um or we just kind of helping them along
with something they're not really sure
what they're doing
um thank you for the question I see the
way it's written I see it more as an
observer like in someone who observes an
election and they would not interfere
with the voter in their process but
would identify
um
an issue with then it when it comes up
and then would Elevate that issue to our
office or ultimately the AG's office
and um my apologies I do want to note
that one of the issues that has happened
in the past is multiple voting where
someone um has requested pre an absentee
ballot from where they came from but
then somebody came in and registered in
the new location and then they
didn't remember that they had voted
previously and voted again in in that in
that town
representative Brennan thank you and
thank you for taking my question
um you talk about this bill being
basically a group effort type of thing
where
as was discussed the idea of having an
event at a nursing home where there are
multiple residents
um filling out these request forms an
absentee ballot forms but
if an individual fills out their own
absentee ballot request form
and
is it the case now and would it still be
the case that a town clerk could would
deliver multiple ballots to a resident
for
multiple residents
does that make sense so is your question
um so would it are you asking whether a
resident would receive multiple ballots
one resident let me rephrase
if 10 residents of a nursing home
residence
were to individually request absentee
ballots
wouldn't the town clerk deliver that
package of 10 individual
absentee ballots at the same time and
wouldn't that constitute delivering
multiple absentee ballots to residents
of nursing homes
and would that then require
two absentee ballot Observers
so that's a good question so my reading
of this is that this would only be
triggered when a clerk or assistant or
their deputized clerk physically goes to
the residence and not does a mailing so
if if you were a resident and you mailed
in a request that request gets sent to
you and then your neighbor requests
another day that request would get sent
to you so this would just occur when
when the group process happens when they
go with multiple applications and
um
and ballots to be filled out at one at
one point in time
Paula please is it not the law now that
a town clerk is able a town clerk or a
deputized representative of the town
clerk to deliver an absentee ballot
to a nursing home facility and and if
that is currently
the law as I think it is
um wouldn't that town clerk potentially
be delivering multiple ballots on any
given day if we're talking about a
nursing home facility with you know 150
residents and there have been 10
individual requests in the span of two
days then a town clerk could potentially
be delivering multiple ballots
at the same time and would that trigger
so are you talking about mail delivery
or hand delivery hand delivery so I've
not heard and it doesn't mean that it
happens that a clerk would choose to
hand deliver the ballots rather than
process them and mail them I think it's
I think we would have to hear from a
town clerk if if there was 100 or
something it would be easier perhaps
time wise and money-wise but otherwise I
don't know that a town clerk would
choose to hand deliver over mail
processing
thank you
perhaps we do need to clarify this is
hand delivery and not mail delivery
good thank you thank you that's any
question
um
Michelle Jacob
hi my name is Michelle Jacob and I'm
here on behalf of our mom this is my
husband Rick
um
in August of 2014 our mom Claire Clara
Jacob was admitted to the Hillsborough
County Nursing Home in Goffstown
on January 16th the durable durable
power of attorney was activated by Dr Dr
B who cared for my mom while at
Hillsborough County Nursing Home
he diagnosed her as having diabetes
unspecified renal failure congestive
heart failure atrial
fibrillation senile dementia and
depressive disorder
quoting him directly
mom was unable to recall her medical
condition
her names of her caregivers Physicians
duration of her stay at the nursing home
and or even how to obtain this
information and this would continue for
the rest of her life
on November 2016 we would go in and
visit her every day and on November 2016
we found an unstamped official absentee
voters ballot envelope in her room that
was addressed to Claire Jacobs
we never discovered why or who
registered to vote under the name Claire
Jacobs her name was Claire Clara Jacob
without an S at the end of her name
and I do have
um some information that we had gotten
from Bill Gardner
and she was registered in Goffstown
under Claire Jacobs
and she was also registered in Goffstown
as clear Jacob
one of them had a voter ID her envelope
had a different voter ID number on it
after discovering this the head nurse of
unit 4C which was our mom's unit she
expressed her extreme discomfort with
the situation knowing mom's Mental
Health
the activities director of Hillsborough
County Nursing Home explained that staff
members distributed the absentee ballots
on the 27th of January in 2017 we spoke
with the Goffstown Town Clerk she told
us that absentee ballots are distributed
at the Hillsborough County Nursing Home
by staff members and that she appoints
as official polling assistants
she explained that the town's Clerk
Office does this to make it easier for
for nursing home residents to vote
mom did not request an absentee ballot
in addition she did not have any form of
identification that would have made it
possible for her to even obtain an
absentee ballot
as her durable power of attorney for
medical as well as finance my husband
was the only one who could have made
that request
mom didn't know she had voted nor that
there was even an election
nor would she even have been able to
fill out any of that information
in November of 2016 she didn't have that
ability
a huge question for us that has never
been answered is who helped her fill out
the ballot and was he or she authorized
or trained to do so
and we spent countless of hours phoning
people writing letters to discover who
and why and how this was allowed to
occur we were never able to get answers
we spoke with Goffstown state
representative Barbara Griffin we spoke
with Bill Gardner we spoke with Al
baldosaro we spoke with Kathy ball we
spoke with secretary Bill Gardner
and it it really and truly is so
unfortunate that this happened to her
and it just wasn't fair yeah if you went
into her room and you said Gee Claire do
you want to vote in the presidential
election well of course she would say
yes if you asked her if she wanted to
make a spaghetti supper for the Knights
of Columbus this week of course I will
so yes while she could say yes she
didn't have the mental capacity to do
any of that and they never had the right
to go into her room period she had no
identification on the outside of her
room except for her name and there were
times when she would come into her room
there would be somebody else sitting in
her chair or laying in her bed oh how
did how does a representative from the
nursing home or anybody else how could
they identify who this person is there's
no identification we go to vote we have
to take out our you know all our license
some identification which is the way it
should be it this this just really is so
wrong
and we pray that it doesn't happen to
other people's other family members you
know
thank you
um just for everybody knows uh the
Hillsborough County Nursing hospital is
in Goffstown just wanted to clear that
yes yes I know I mean and so the whole
nursing home got these ballots
regardless of who they were
so someone mentioned how many people got
them the town clerk said they delivered
them
and I'm on the Hillsborough County
executive committee and I think that's a
question I'm going to ask next time so
is there any questions
and thank you for that thank you
now I like to call up Susan Buxton
thank you
good afternoon chairman and members of
the committee thank you for allowing me
to testify today my name is Susan Buxton
I'm the state long-term care ombudsman
the long-term care Ombudsman is a
required program of states that receive
any older Americans act funds which
obviously New Hampshire does our office
Works to resolve problems related to
health safety welfare and rights of
individuals who live in nursing homes
assisted livings and other Residential
Care Facilities
we do this through education
investigation mediation and advocacy
the Ombudsman programs promote policies
and consumer protections that support
well-being of individuals that live in
long-term care
so I came today with my position being
neutral because I I really had some
questions after reviewing the bill about
what the purpose and of the bill was and
what it was seeking to address I do feel
like I have a little better
understanding after listening to the
testimony before me but some of the
points that I make in my written
testimony and I'd like to share today
remain and that is
if the goal is to increase access to
absentee voting for people living in
long-term care I think that is a good
thing it is challenging for people that
are living in long-term care to vote and
there are there are you know many
reasons that that people want to vote by
absentee but the main reasons being
they're receiving short-term
Rehabilitation care and they're unable
to to go to their polling place
um they lack Transportation or because
ambulatory ambulation or care needs make
it difficult for them to go to a polling
place
but if this bill is written to make this
a required process for all individuals
who live in a nursing home or Assisted
Living
seeking to execute their right to vote I
think that it's creating an unnecessary
and unfair burden and I would oppose it
anyone in this room can can request a
ballot and fill it out in the privacy of
their home and mail it in and
individuals that are living in in
long-term care settings that's their
home
um
they should be able to to follow the
same procedures that anyone any other
citizen of the state is allowed to
follow
so I would support the bill if it's
clearly stating that it's expanding the
options for exercising the right to vote
that are that are residing in long-term
care but as I said I would I would
oppose it if it's if it's further
restricting their abilities
um I'll talk a little bit about my
experience I've worked in long-term care
for my whole career so I'll say it's
it's over 25 years without giving up my
age and I have been involved with
assisting residents that want to vote
and you heard before me people talk
about there are a number of individuals
who have dementia that live in our
long-term care facilities
and while
the entire process may seem overwhelming
it's it's very often that they have a
very clear belief that they want to vote
and they understand it
and you know I think we need to be very
thoughtful and careful
about determining whether somebody has
capacity or not to vote because that's
to my knowledge not a requirement
so
you
you may have to assist somebody who has
dementia by reading the ballot to them
because they may not be able to look at
it and read it and understand it
but they may still have a very clear
opinion
and I I I recognize the challenges of
somebody having the skills and abilities
to assist somebody with dementia and not
impart their opinion and so I would I
would applaud the efforts to to make
sure that the rights of the individuals
are protected during that process
um
for instance I have known individuals
who felt very very strongly about their
political party and so they might not
have any idea who the candidates are
but they know that they want to vote for
whoever is that member of that party
that they have always supported have
supported and so they may say that I I I
don't know who any of them are but make
sure I want to make sure that I vote
Republican or I vote Democrat so
you know I think we need to be really
thoughtful when we when we design this
because
I'm not sure the way that it's written I
don't think that you would be putting
that person that's an observer is not
qualified to determine whether somebody
knows what they're doing or not
so
um
the the only other thing that I really
want to point out to you and I think it
probably speaks to the fact that the
town clerks may be opposing that is
there are 78 nursing homes and 139
assisted living facilities in New
Hampshire and there are 14 000 residents
and those are not spaced evenly across
the state so you know I selected one
Community which is Bedford which has
five assisted living homes and three
nursing homes and 900 residents
so you know we need to think about what
that means for for each individual town
and I I would be thrilled if every
facility created a polling place so that
individuals could vote but I think we
need to be
careful about that I'm happy to answer
any questions
thank you any questions
thank you very much
oh who
now everybody looked that one I
appreciate it's okay I appreciate that
thank you I appreciate the information
about how many facilities there are and
it raises the question I guess whether
if if this bill written by the Secretary
of State I guess
um
were to pass
you know it raises the question about
whether Town clerks would be able to
find a sufficient number of observers to
accompany them
and when they deliver the ballots and
also when the ballots are being
distributed marked and collected and and
I presume that if you couldn't find The
Observers then then you couldn't do the
delivery and you couldn't distribute the
ballots and that could disenfranchise a
relatively large number of the Fourteen
thousand people in these homes is that
is that one of your that's my point yep
is that it's going to be an undue burden
for some towns that have a high
concentration
representative Brennan
I'll make it quick thank you
thank you for taking my question is
there ever a scenario where and this is
similar to the question I asked earlier
is there ever a scenario where the
family of a person in a nursing home has
the ability to
remove that person's right to vote or
no nobody has the authority to determine
whether somebody can vote even in a
guardianship which is the most
restrictive
appointment
most most Wards those individuals that
have been appointed a guardian retain
the right to vote so a power of attorney
absolutely does not have the authority
to determine whether or not somebody
should be allowed to vote thank you
okay anymore okay good thank you
now with that I remember what can you
give me the blue sheet and I believe
there's nobody else wanting to speak
so in a minute we'll move on to our next
bill
which is uh 586.
196 yeah
so we have
one person four and
five people against
okay now a next bill
is representative Faulkner here
I got my pink card I throw those out
over here
thank you Mr chair and committee members
right
I made a serious mistake I emailed
everyone an amendment and I didn't I
failed to match it so Joel should have
an amendment that could go with okay
with this with 586
you the previous Bill okay okay thank
you
okay
now on to 586.
sure thank you I'm Barry Faulkner I
represent the Swansea in Richmond
Chester 10 and I'm the prime sponsor of
this bill it's relatively simple Bill
compared to the last one anyway I I hope
that you might agree
uh the inspiration for this bill came
around election time when somebody
published a poll or opinion statement
that
placed New Hampshire at the bottom of
the list of 50 states in terms of the
most difficult state to vote in I said
geez
proud New Hampshire native I resent that
remark and you know I know for a fact
it's not true
you know well you have a lot of things
going for us I think we have one of the
better voting systems in the country
I've observed elections all over the
country four different states I've run
elections I've participated as a party
Representatives candidate
account all our ballots on Election Day
we have an easy
straightforward registration process you
can register on the day of election
uh we don't have lines
by enlarging at least not the way other
states do things work pretty well here
but I did look kind of over things to
see what you know
what can be done to make things a little
bit easier for people to vote in the
state so
looking at the absentee ballot
statute which in fact provides an outlet
for people who can't be there
on Election Day
for a variety of reasons
and realize there are a couple of
reasons that people have expressed to me
for why they didn't show up the boat or
why they
were considering not voting so I'm
posing two additional reasons that would
be placed on the absentee ballot
application
one reason is I can't get a ride I don't
have a car
transportation is a problem
the second reason is that I
have concerns about going out in public
either for my own safety or my own
health or for the health of others
don't have a disability but I have a
deep concern about
about my health if I go out into a crowd
so
two simple reasons that would be placed
on the on the uh on the application that
would allow people to uh
participate by absentee ballot when they
can't or have serious reservations about
showing up an election day
the only other change that's made is
that the
violations of the absentee ballot
statute
are treated the same as other violations
of of
voting statutes in terms of um
of the required level of men's Raya to
uh to prosecute
so it's it's pretty simple the bill is
long just because the statute reproduces
the
the application in full and so
we've reprinted the entire application
with those two additional
additional reasons on there and um
hope that that might be a simple
perhaps not earth-shaking addition to
our
our system and we're following the
existing absentee ballot system there's
no additional work
let's get counted along with other
absentee ballots
it's
you know still observing that the the
principle that people
cast absentee ballots because they can't
or have difficulty being at the election
place on Election Day it's not a radical
change from any of that so I hope that
this might be seen as being one small
step we can make to make things easier
to vote in this state
thank you
thank you any questions
okay with that thank you all right thank
you and then I'll call
deputy secretary of state and here in
Tennessee
good afternoon everyone Aaron Hennessey
deputy secretary of state
um good to see you again
um our office is opposed to this bill
we see this as a bill that's trying to
micromanage micromanage the number of
instances
um for requesting an absentee ballot
some of which may not be
um in line with what our constitution
allows
I think that you could all sit around
all day long and come up with a number
of scenarios where somebody might come
up with an instance where they can't
come to the polls
um unlike the last bill
um in regards to nursing homes our
office does not get a lot of calls from
people who cannot get to the polls we do
get a lot of calls about nursing homes
and not getting ballots or issues with
voting at nursing homes and complaints
but um I was able to ask someone who was
in our office for 49 and a half years
how many calls she received over those
that time period related to not being
able to get to the polls and she thinks
that there was probably six
for which she referred to that person's
political party to request a ride for
them so I didn't I don't see that as an
issue with adding this to the
um the affidavit envelope or the
absentee ballot request form I think you
all are aware that this committee is
trying to re reduce the size of the
alphabet affidavit envelope and make it
easier or reduce the information on the
absentee application and make it easier
for somebody to understand and this
would just add more information and make
it more confusing versus less
happy to take questions
any questions
thank you thank you good off easy today
okay uh Olivia zinc
to turn your mic there you go
should know I should know the the drill
um for the record my name is Olivia Zink
executive director of open democracy and
nonpartisan non-profit Pro voter
organization with 36 000 members
um and I live in the city of Franklin
um absentee voting is nonpartisan
according to the Institute of responsive
Government research has shown that
neither party gains an advantage when
they're voting by absentee and when
voting by absentee is expanded
democracy thrives when many of us can
participate so removing barriers to
participation encourages a healthy
democracy
and expanding the deaf definition of
absentee benefits everyone including
seniors who might not be driving anymore
rule rule voters
single parents families whose kids get
sick or somebody or dicey weather
according to the ncsl
35 states have no excuse absentee voting
so you don't need an excuse to vote by
absentee
during the pandemic many exposed some
fundamental weak weaknesses to our
absentee voting and voter registration
when town clerk's office is closed
in 2020 and 2022 those voters who were
fearful were able to claim physical
disability to vote by absentee
and it all there was also in 2020 an
allowance for pre-processing absentee
which we knew election workers really
enjoyed that opportunity and I think
it's really important for us
to think about this as
we
we're all adults everyone who's a voter
is over 18 and is adult and they should
manage whether they go in person or
whether they can request an absentee
ballot and it's really important for
voters to have a choice on how they want
their vote to be counted and
um that their ability to participate
I did have an opportunity to serve on
the special committee for voter
competence
um and they're in our final report we
said consideration should be given for
pre-processing absentee ballots so I do
think that if we are expanding absentee
balloting that we should allow for Town
clerks to expand pre-processing please
side with voters by voting House Bill
586 ought to pass and allowing voters to
vote securely by an absentee ballot
um it's really important for our for New
Hampshire's future I'm happy to take any
questions thank you any questions
seeing none thank you
now Mackenzie Saint-Germain
good afternoon chairman members of the
committee my name is Mackenzie St
Germain I'm with the New Hampshire
campaign for voting rights I'm an
America votes New Hampshire and I'm here
today in support of HB 586 as a
coalition the New Hampshire campaign for
voting rights is committed to supporting
legislation that expands and supports
voter access which is exactly what this
bill does by expanding absentee voting
to those who have concerns about their
safe safety or health traveling to or
being at the polls and those who don't
have affordable or reliable
transportation we would ensure that more
eligible voters are able to cast their
ballots no voter should be prevented
from participating because of concerns
about their health being at the polls
about their safety traveling to the
polls or finding an affordable ride and
being able to get there I know myself
I've talked to voters on election day
going door to door who said I wasn't my
ride fell through I wasn't able to get
there this would allow those voters who
don't have that that reliable
transportation to ensure their vote
counts was recently told and I got my
car inspected that although I passed I
probably should not drive in winter
weather because of the state of my tires
there are many many cases we could go
through those voters still deserve to be
able to cast their ballot and to not
have the additional burden of only being
able to go on Election Day when they're
not able to get there safely or they're
not able to travel there because of
Transportation issues it's also
important to know as the previous person
testified that this is a nonpartisan
absentee voting does not benefit one
party or another and I'll encourage you
all to remember as you work through any
absentee voting bills that in New
Hampshire the local election officials
are still at the heart of this process
they're the ones who send out and
process the ballots and voters do need
to sign their envelopes attestings their
identity domicile age and citizenship so
there are in absentee voting really
important levels of security and local
role in the process and this bill would
only expand that access to voters to be
able to participate so thank you and I
am happy to take any questions
and do we have any questions
and with that thank you thank you
um representative wood would you the
blue sheet there's no more people to
want to speak
we can
in a minute
close this earring
and we have
read
three people signed to support it
with that include the hearing on
586 and start exec session in a half
hour
take a break
um
yes
that's true
foreign
thank you
okay
foreign
all right
let's get rolling
okay
thank you representative Boom for
helping me stall for time
so we're gonna do two out of order to
give representative Ankerberg a chance
to get back here from his sub Duty
across the hall
so let's open the executive session on
[Music]
in this executive session will be
recessed to 10 A.M
Tuesday March 14th and I can't speak any
slower
thank you
alrighty we're gonna jump to house bill
447.
representative Lane is recognized for a
motion
thank you Mr chair I move that we retain
this particular Bill to give us time to
oh
you got a motion in a second
I need a second yeah we need a second
okay
it's g-r-i-o
in case you needed help
representative Lane would you like to
speak to your motion thank you uh we
would like to have some time to work on
an amendment Amendment uh and we
we uh working with OLS and there's a
small group of us working together on
the amendment
okay and hopefully they kick it because
next Tuesday is literally our last day
okay
further discussion on the bill
okay the motion is retain House Bill 447
the clerk will call the roll please
representative prudhome O'Brien yes
representative Bohm yeah
representative qualey yes
representative inkerberg
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy yes
representative done
representative wood yes
representative pamonti
yes did I get that right okay Monty
correct
representative Lane
yes
representative Ward yeah
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative Muirhead yes
representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Smith
yes
that is 19 years and one not voting
and House Bill 447 is retained another
chapter in what I did with my son
your hesitation was funny I actually did
vote against my own motion once
something devastating came up in the
executive session on the bill and holy
cow they're right yeah no
we will take a 10 minute recess while I
go stare angrily at the other committee
foreign
little time now now we'll do them in
order
we'll open the executive session on
House Bill 179 representative bones
recognized for a motion
I second that
foreign
thank you would you like to speak stream
motion
I was used to it over there
but anyway
I think yeah this has been hassled out
before so I think that currently let's
sort of leave it like again
that's all I have to say
yeah the way I understood this was you
know wearing paraphernalia
um is allowed now I wouldn't even be
comfortable with that but I think this
bill adds that poll workers can also
wear political advertising so that's why
I think we don't want to pass it
further discussion on the bill
okay the motion is itl on House Bill 179
roll call please representative prudhome
O'Brien yes
representative Bohm yeah
representative qualey yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy
representative Dunn yes
representative wood yes
representative pimonte
yes
representative lean yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative weirhead
representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Smith yes
that is 28 28 sorry
and no Nays
but I want to move consent
foreign
representative Kennedy that was pretty
succinct you want to take a swing at the
report
thank you
Ralph's already got a couple so
um
Kennedy right
I might misspell some names and we don't
okay none of the rest oh and shut up
line is complete okay
all right and the Motions about to 209
will be next
we're good to go
open the executive session on House Bill
209 representative Kennedy is recognized
promotion uh Mr chairman I move that
house bill 209b itl
somebody want a second uh I'll second
the motion
would you like to speak to emotion
yeah I I think my colleague has some
more specific objections to this bill
but
you know for myself this is just another
step down the path where we effectively
end in-person voting somewhere down the
line and I am not in favor of that
further discussion on the bill
Mr chairman representative queli yes as
my as our colleague mentioned my uh
concerns are a bit more specific
as I see this bill it it it's attempting
to modify the absentee ballot
application uh it it's implementing
uh qualifications for absentee voting
that are defined elsewhere in the
statutes
and these I believe that an application
implementing a set of qualifications in
the statute should be consistent with
those qualific qualifications as defined
this bill has introduced
makes the application less consistent
with the defined qualifications rather
than more consistent specifically
the qualifications currently defined in
RSA 657 colon 1 include a provision
for uh
qualifying for
absentee voting if there is a National
Weather Service winter storm or Blizzard
or ice storm warning for the day of the
election
the application form is specified as
proposed in this bill does not include
that
qualification so it is explicitly
inconsistent with the qualifications
listed in the statutes I think that's
not a good thing because it could lead
to confusion on the part of Voters
a second inconsistency is that it
changes the term
qualifications physical disability
as mentioned in 657 colon 1 to Simply
disability which is a more General
qualification than what is specified in
the other statute I think that's also
unwise introduce such inconsistencies
and if there is a belief that the
qualifications to vote absentee should
be changed those changes should be made
in these statutes which Define them to
begin with
thank you
for the discussion on the bill
in my blind spot sorry
I had an amendment for this bill
but we're not on amendments we're on the
motion
so we can't amend it or we're just gonna
ital it we can't discuss an amendment
representative
I guess can we discuss
Among Us during the before we vote
there's no Amendment before the no I
understand that I guess I have a
question for representative quailey
oh yeah there's further discussion on
the bill so if if you knew that there
was an amendment that would address
these issues would that
assist would that improve the bill in
your opinion that's possible but I
haven't I haven't done the members do
not cross-question each other right and
again also there is no Amendment before
us right now
okay
further discussion on the bill
yes it's parliamentary gymnastics
let me try to help a little
if you want to discuss an issue in the
underlying bill that could be fixed
without saying the a word since there is
no amendments before the committee
and you can't amend on an itl if you can
work that without me wearing out my
hammer you might get away with it but
you cannot say Amendment or discuss
anything in the amendment that does not
yet exist
um
yeah that's fine
ah representative Brennan you want to
take a swing at it
um my colleague across the way mentioned
that the bill is written does not or
that the bill as written simplifies the
disability qualification for requesting
an absentee ballot
um and makes it so that it simply says
disability instead of physical
disability but I'm not seeing that
physical disability is in the statute
and I'm wondering if someone can point
out where a physical disability is the
only disability qualification for
requesting an absentee ballot
representative quality do you have that
information
I believe I do give me a moment to find
it in the relevant statute sure thing
the
it's a fifth 657 colon one
uh
section Roman numeral I
uh hang on a second
uh who is or who is unable to vote there
in person by reason of physical
disability
and as an aside that's also the language
used in our state constitution
thank you for the question thank you for
the discussion thank you
because we're discussing a form I'm
looking at
um 657 colon 4 which says application
forms and the application form as it
currently stands
simply says disability and not physical
disability so I would just like to point
out that the bill currently as written
does not make a change to the form
as it currently stands in regards to
disability well done
and thank you because the next time
somebody says it's impossible I can't do
it I'm just going to have them call you
further discussion on the bill Mr
chairman
representative I'm aware of other
existing inconsistencies with the form
defined in 657 for
that
I believe should also be made consistent
with the with the statutes that Define
the qualifications
and that's all I have to say on that I
think the whole I think the form should
be made consistent with the statute that
defines the qualifications for absentee
voting that includes all
inconsistencies and including those
which currently exist
thank you
it would be awesome if
members of the committee over the summer
before the fall
went through that because I hate that
and figure out where the inconsistencies
are and make a match that would be a
really good useful can be proud of
projects for the committee to file in
the fall
represent Brennan
um would my colleague like to point out
the inconsistencies that he sees
um as the bill currently stands in
relation to the statute regarding the
form so that perhaps we may be able to
address those inconsistencies
you want to I would like to
make a further comment on this subject
which is that no I don't see it would be
a useful uh productive use of our time
at this point the the inconsistencies
are there to be cleanly clearly seen in
my opinion by anyone who compares the
two statutes I would like to point out
that
starting about two years ago it was a
bill by former representative Bergeron I
believe was HP 44.
in which we we did that representative
Muirhead I think would remember
participating in that so I think HP 44
if you want to pursue it would be a good
place to start it was a bill that
that uh
cleared the committee 20-0 when we were
done and I recall that it passed uh in a
house session
but
then went astray in the other chamber of
the legislature
and thank you again
if there was one yeah
for the discussion on the bill
all right I have a parliamentary
question so sure
if we
Ito
TL does that mean can we bring a new one
next session that addresses the
inconsistencies or does it mean we are
off the table so to speak
um until the next session not next year
but next session
as long as the bill is substantively
different
and I can explain that to the speaker it
should be okay
as far as I'm willing to go with my
answer so
it's that substantively word there is no
definition written down
and the intent of the rule is to keep
sore losers from just filing the same
thing over and over and over again
I don't believe that's the case here
is it in
a sure is it uh could we have five
minutes two uh
caucus
sure thing why not thank you we are in
recess
so do you mean five
Maybe
do you mean five minutes okay so we're
in recess till 3 40.
all right and we're out of recess
and still executing House Bill 209 was
there any further discussion
okay
or call the roll please the motion is
inexperiod to legislator on house built
true or not representative prudhome
O'Brien yes
representative boom yes
representative qualey yes
representative inkerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy yes
representative Dunn yes
representative wood yes
representative pamonte
yes
representative Lane yes
representative Ward
yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative weirhead yeah
representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Smith yes
that is 20 2-0 on itl
any objections to consent
all right consent it shall be
uh Kennedy
yeah
ready
all right now we'll open the executive
session on House Bill 336 representative
Bowman was recognized for a motion
somebody want a second second
boom Kennedy would you like to speak to
your motion yeah
vote
yeah
so even in
like in like there's only two people I
mean there are Underpants
representative Howard
hey Mr chairman uh I I think that this
bill uh it solves an issue that many of
many of us including myself uh have
experienced in serving in a multi-member
district
I had gone through a recount this past
cycle and I had seen a number of ballots
where there were a number of undervotes
I think that the language that currently
exists can be confusing to individuals
because they are afraid that their vote
will not be counted if they vote for too
many candidates
this changes the language so that it
encourages them to vote for additional
candidates up until the maximum rather
than encouraging them to be more
conservative with their vote
I encourage you all to support this bill
thanks
for the discussion on the bill
representative Hamlet
thank you Mr chair
um I passed out an amendment that I was
hoping to introduce
for this Bill yes the a word
um because there is some confusion among
some voters about how how many
candidates are they actually allowed to
vote for and this bill
helps to clarify that for voters and the
amendment would have clarified it even
further
thank you
further discussion on the bill
representative Brennan thank you
the bill has written clarifies and
changes the language so that on the
ballot there is more positive language
there is something to be said for the
way that the ballot is currently written
using the language not more than there
is a negative connotation there and that
contributes to the confusion with voters
this bill as written contains a lot of
words but perhaps there might be a
simplified version for this committee to
consider
and I would encourage my colleagues to
possibly consider a second motion
instead of the one currently before us
for the discussion
okay so the motion is inexperienced to
legislate on
house bill
336.
representative prudhome O'Brien yes
representative Bohm
representative qualey yes
representative Ankerberg no
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy yes
representative Dunn yes
representative wood yes
representative pamonte
yes
representative Lane no
representative Ward no
representative Hamer no
representative Hamlet no
representative Moorhead
representative Bay no
representative Brennan no
representative Grill no representative
Howard no
representative Palmer no
representative Smith yes
that makes nine years to 11 days
on itl and the motion fails
okay
um
thank you Mr chair
um I would like to move uh to pass on
the amendment to House Bill
336. we're gonna need it we adopt don't
and we need a positive motion first okay
I could I please change my motion sure I
I move ought to pass on House Bill 336.
there a second
and now would you like to offer an
amendment
yes thank you Mr chair
so
um I would like to move out to pass on
Amendment the amendment to House Bill
336 which is amendment 2023-0736h
representative Hamlet moves
amendment0736h is there a second
got it
thank you would like to speak to your
motion yes thank you Mr chair
so the amendment
makes the language even more clear to
instruct voters as to how to vote when
there are you know one or more uh
offices to vote for on on the ballot
so
um in line seven
um
it changes the word from from the
original bill it changes the word from
each such to appropriate So Below the
appropriate phase a phrase shall be
printed in small but easily legible
letters and then it gives two Clear
Choices
um number one is to
um
vote for one if there's only one office
to be filled such as the governor or
state senator
or vote for up to
X number
uh where you would insert the number of
offices to be filled X will be elected
so insert the number of offices to be
filled so it instructs the voter that
they are allowed to vote for
um the number of offices
uh that are allowed to be filled
on the ballot for that position
further discussion on the amendment
isn't this nice to turn around we can't
talk about the bill just the amendment
so it's kind of like the opposite of
before
representative yeah thank you uh
to me this makes it
get wrong information
because it says vote for up to X
meaning I have to vote for up to X
which is the current language that not
more than which makes I don't have to
vote up to X
so this says according to this the
instructions vote for up to X in other
words up to 10 up to five or whatever
the number is that are running I might
not want to and this is giving me wrong
information
with the vote for up to X thank you
further discussion on the bill
representative Ankerberg my response to
that would be that it's also telling you
how many how many seats or candidates
are being elected that you're voting for
so in my view I see it exactly the
opposite it's actually providing
information to me
further discussion on the amendment
sure representative Brennan thank you
this amendment remember don't talk about
the bill I will not this amendment
offers Clarity to voters it makes it
exceedingly clear how many seats there
are how many seats how many individuals
will be elected to those seats it makes
it easier
and
more clear
for the voter which I think all of my
colleagues would like to see when it
comes to the ballot we want people to
understand how to fill out their ballot
this makes it easier
I encourage my colleagues to vote
otpa
on this amendment please and thank you
representative Burnham
thank you Mr chair
um so yeah I agree that this
amendment has a lot more clarity I have
found working at elections for the last
10 or so years
many voters are confused when they see
the word not I get confused when I see
not because it's telling me not to do
something
but that's not what it meant it's meant
to do but it's confusing and you still
have a choice to not vote for that many
people so I think that this taking the
knot out
doesn't confuse the individual
and just provides a clear statement
this money is available to vote
and choose how you vote
thank you
representative Muirhead I'd just like to
briefly address the argument made by my
colleague with the excellent tie
that this might cause people not to
Bullet vote and I think if it said let's
say in a 4C District but said vote for
four candidates then that might cause it
says vote for up to four I think that
does tell the voter that they don't have
to do all four they could just vote for
one representative burn them if that's
the person I know and want a bullet for
so I think
um I don't I think it preserves that
option for voters
further discussion
representative Hammer thank you I just
wanted to just wanted to say that vote
for up to up to it sounds more inviting
than vote for not more than so I agree
further discussion on the bill
representative
I used to teach survey classes and
um one of the things that we teach is to
not ask the question with negative just
not so this is consistent with that
all right further discussion before we
get too carried away I can count so
representative wood
it's interesting that we keep the
negative for the vote for not more than
one we keep that negative and the other
one seems to be more positive so I just
I don't know
Mr chair
thank you
and we haven't voted on the amendment
yet right okay further discussion on the
amendment
representative yeah I I told him yeah
the amended language
does make it clearer than the original
language
so I'm just one you know so that I think
clarifies it vote for up to the number
not more than I don't think it makes
that much different
representative Brennan I'll keep it
brief thank you Mr chair
um just to address my colleague
representative Woods comment about vote
for not more than one in the case of say
Governor
um that language
helps a voter understand when you have
um
one candidate for the Democratic side
one candidate for the Republican side
you're not creating a situation where
that person
um
would choose more than one on that line
whereas in a state representative race
where someone may choose to vote for
some Democrats some Republicans some
third party the language is clear for
vote for up to but it's important for
the single seat of a governor's race to
have the negative language of vote for
not more than so that the voter gets the
signal that they cannot vote for more
than one or they risk their vote not
being counted
so that would be the argument for
maintaining the language that's in this
amendment
as it is thank you
all right
okay and go ahead and I think it's time
we got to the vote
thank you uh
think that
for consistency throughout the entire
ballot I'm going to vote against the
amendment
and I am going that's my plan because
if you are saying one thing for a race
with one person in it that you can vote
for
you're saying you'd be phrasing it the
exact same way in every other race and I
I think that's best I personally
all right
let's take a flyer and see how this
turns out so the uh
the motion is whether to adopt Amendment
zero seven three six h
representative purdom O'Brien no
representative boom no
Representative qualey no
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy
representative Dunn no
representative wood no
representative Monty
no
representative Lane
yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative Muirhead
representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Smith yes
that is
13 years and seven Nays and the
Amendments adopted
the question now is on
ought to pass as amended
on House Bill 366.
let's just replace the
okie dokie I just wanted to make sure I
was right so
the amendment replaces section one not
Roman numeral one regular number one I
wish we didn't do that but we do
the only thing remaining of the original
bill is section two regular number two
which was the effective date
so what you're looking at
is this
it's the whole bill the amendment with
an effective date of 60 days after
Passage
so
discussion on
the bill as amended
okay
oh somebody hi boy those corner seats
are a problem
thank you Mr chip so do we need an
amendment of ought to pass
I mean the emotion about to pass nope
you already did it okay
so I would just like to say that house
bill 336 as amended makes it much more
clear to the voters about how many uh
candidates to vote for
thank you
anybody else
okay then the motion is
ought to pass on House Bill
336 with Amendment zero seven three six
h
representative prudomo Brian yes
representative bone
representative qualey yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy no
representative Dunn yes
representative wood yes
representative pamonte
yes
representative Lane yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative mirhood
representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Smith why not yes
that is 19 years and one nay
thank you representative candidate
representative Hamlet made the motion so
we will do the report please yeah and in
the report it is important to explain
what the amendment does okay do you
remember on the house floor that's
actually the first vote
so the folks need to be able to look at
a report and know what they're voting on
okay
there you go
honestly you only need the last okay
four plus the h
okay
do I need to do anything for minority
like that should be if there was a
Minority Report
okay that was weird right yeah
did I close that
I can't remember if I closed it
well I'll hit it again so that closes
and now we will open executive session
on House Bill
363 representative Kennedy you recognize
promotion better luck this time uh thank
you Mr chairman I make a motion for
House Bill 363 363
ought to pass
anybody going to back them up
we need a second
Mueller
I'm sorry
alrighty would you like to speak to
emotion
briefly
um this this bill doesn't seem to change
things a whole lot it it uh I think it
cleans up some potential problems
between people who are running in a
primary and people who are not
fair enough anybody else
okay
the motion is ought to pass on House
Bill 363. please call the roll right
home O'Brien uh yes
representative boom yes
representative qualey yes
representative inkerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy yes
representative Dunn yes
representative wood yes
representative uh pamonti AC yes
representative Lane no
representative Ward no
representative Hamer no
representative Hamlet no
representative Muirhead
representative Bay no
representative Brennan no
representative Grill no
representative Howard no
representative Palmer no
representative Smith yes
10 to 10. and the motion fails
representative land
I'd like to make a motion for itl
representative Lane moves and experience
to legislate is there a second
percent of Base seconds
and do you want to speak to your motion
no
Mark of experience there
but oh dear representative Brennan
cool thank you
[Laughter]
my colleague who is missing today uh
representative Barry often points out
that two classifications of Voters and
this bill creates two classifications
for candidates and for that reason I
would encourage my colleagues to support
the itl motion so that candidates are
treated equally much like we
or a friend who is not here today would
like voters to be treated equally and so
please support the itl motion so the
candidates are treated equally thank you
for the discussion
okay
so the motion is an expedient to
legislate on house bill 363.
representative prudhoma Brian no
representative Bohm no
Representative qualey no
representative Ankerberg nope
representative Burnham no
representative Kennedy no
representative Dunn no
representative wood no
representative pamonte no
representative lien yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative mayorhud
representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative grow yes
representative Howard yes representative
Palmer yes
representative Smith
no
another 10 to 10.
and that motion fails that means that
this will go to the house calendar with
no recommendation and I will need
reports from what representative Lynn
and representative Kennedy foreign
all right we'll open the executive
session on House Bill 460.
representative perdoma Brian is
recognized promotional
thank you Mr chairman I moved ought to
pass
second
okay uh would you like to speak to your
motion yes thank you Mr chairman
I think we need
an accuracy accurate assessment of all
people who vote
um
that all people who vote should be
qualified voters
and all all people who vote should bring
ID and have ID it's not too much to ask
I don't think it's too cumbersome and I
don't think it's
it's uh
it would lead to voter suppression
so for that reason I support this bill
spread the discussion on the bill
represent Brennan thank you
um
as we remember from the public hearing
there were there was a lot of discussion
about this bill one thing that I'd like
to point out to my colleagues who are
considering supporting the ought to pass
motion is that this bill
well it seeks to remove
affidavits
from the voter registration process
there are
a in this bill there are places where it
mentions that affidavits are acceptable
for proving certain things so while this
bill seeks to remove affidavits from the
registration process you are still able
to use an affidavit so if the issue is
with affidavits
in the registration process
why would it still be acceptable to use
affidavits to prove other portions that
are included in this bill I hope that's
making sense
it's been a long day
um
so what I'm trying to say is affidavits
are not a problem we have we use them
all the time for all sorts of different
things including in this bill
that is trying to declare the affidavits
are a problem
I would encourage my colleagues not to
support the ought to pass motion so that
another motion may be made thank you
further discussion on the bill
okay
so the motion is ought to pass on House
Bill 460 rolls on
representative credoma Brian yes
representative Bohm yeah
representative quaily yes
representative inkerberg yes
representative Brenham yes
representative Kennedy
representative Dunn yes
representative wood yes
representative pamonti yes
representative lean no
representative Ward no
representative Hamer no
representative Hamlet no
representative Muirhead
representative Bay
no
representative Brennan no
representative Grill no
representative Howard no
representative Palmer no
representative Smith
yes
10 to 10.
and the motion fails
representative Howard
all motion itl
Howard moves ICL is there a second
do we want to discuss further
rep Senator Brennan
I recognize that my colleagues half of
my colleagues have supported the ought
to pass motion but I would encourage you
to consider changing your mind and
voting Ito on this we heard during
testimony that there is no widespread
voter fraud
there is no falsifying of documents
there are no
issues
that have not been handled appropriately
by the ages office there was no
testimony to say that the AG's office is
overwhelmed with following up on
affidavit
um
for voter registration or voting
purposes
um
there is in with this bill a chilling
effect
that would affect voters who are seeking
to vote which is what I believe we all
would like to see an increase in voter
participation and we do not want to have
someone discouraged
from voting because
of some new
legislation
that would turn them away I'd also like
to point out that this bill does not
recognize the rights of people who are
currently
houseless or homeless
those citizens do have a right to vote
and they may not have the documentation
but they would still be allowed to vote
under our current system with the
affidavit this bill removes that option
from a segment of our population during
a time where we are experiencing a
housing crisis
those folks those homeless individuals
deserve the opportunity to vote
and this bill takes that away from them
and it is a fundamental right that is
being stripped from them with this bill
please consider that especially during
this time
of a housing crisis
too many people
currently without a home but still
deserve the right to vote
represent Kendrick yeah I just wanted to
point out that the the idea that there
are no problems with our elections is an
opinion it's not a fact
well it's not going to go back and forth
the most Fair statement to say is there
is no evidence of widespread voter fraud
the one side believes there is not any
and the other side believes that if you
don't look for it properly you don't
find it and neither side will convince
each other that they have the correct
answer and there's no evidence to
support either side so let's not do that
okay
all right
further discussion
let's get to it then I I do have some
private discussion representative Brian
thank you I just want to mention that I
will be voting no on the itl but that
does not mean I'm not concerned about
homeless people voting because they can
use the shelter addresses and that is
something that has been addressed in law
and what does have a chilling effect and
what I hear from my constituents is when
an affidavit Vote or a vote that someone
fills out an affidavit that's
abandon is a dead end and you can't find
the person that has a chilling effect on
voter confidence and that's why I'll be
voting itl but it's not out of lack of
concern for the same people that
represented Brennan discussed
further discussion
all right
let's call the role the motion is an
expedient to legislate on House Bill 46.
representative pradome O'Brien no
representative boom no
Representative qualey no
representative Ankerberg nope
representative Burnham no
representative Kennedy no
representative Dunn no
representative wood no
representative pamonte
no
representative Lane yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative Muirhead
representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative girl yes representative
Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Smith
no
10 to 10
.
and the motion fails so this will be no
recommendation
need reports from
representative Howard and representative
perdom O'Brien
so and before I gavel the executive
session I just want to point out
something maybe not all of you know when
I chaired transportation we created a
program so that unhoused people could
get ideas and licenses even with the
address on it of an accredited shelter
so if you've got people coming to you
because they need help getting an ID and
they're unhoused it's a good
opportunity to hook them up with support
people that can maybe help them with
other services
there's also a lot of other things that
you can do to help them as was a
legislator legislature's representative
for four years on the governor's
interagency Council on homelessness that
was appointed by both Hassan and then
sununu so there's a lot available in
their biggest challenges that people
don't send them to these agencies so
maybe try to do that and they can
absolutely get a license if they can
drive or an ID and that's important to
get a job and that's important to get
housing and you know it just kind of
Cascades from there
and that's my sermon for the day and
that closes the executive session on
House Bill 460.
good to go we'll open the executive
session on House Bill 484
representative Quail is recognized for a
motion
thank you Mr chairman I move that the
committee fined HB 484 in expedient to
legislate thank you
family moves ICL and the Committee
Member with the most letters in her name
is the
subscribe
for her all right would you like to
speak to your motion yes I would thank
you Mr chairman
we heard testimony
during the public hearing that the
number of
absentee ballots which have been
employed the most recent general
election was considerable considerably
reduced from uh the height in 2020.
which suggests to me that the workload
involved in processing absentee ballots
was also reduced and powering hopefully
another pandemic type situation we can
expect that to continue in the future
so I see little benefit in opening the
ballots the outer envelopes the absentee
ballots earlier than is currently the
practice on on Election Day
I do however see
an increased risk of ballots being
mishandled absentee ballots being
mishandled utter envelopes are opened
sooner
the more we handle the ballots the more
likelihood there is of mishandling and
the subsequent confusion and chaos and
drama
thank you
further discussion on the bill
okay
so the motion is inexperienced to
legislator on House Bill 484.
representative predom O'Brien yes
representative boom yeah
representative quilly yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy yes
representative Dunn yes
representative wood yes
representative pamonti hey yes
representative Lane yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative weirhead yeah
representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative girl yes
representative Howard yes
representative Palmer yes representative
Smith
yes
20-0
any objections to consent
okay
so representative quaily on your report
no I just got a 20-zip vote I have
nothing for you just write down what you
said
foreign
all right let's open the executive
session on House Bill 495.
representative Brian's recognized for
motion I move itl
I second the motion
Billy
would you like to speak to your motion
yes I I would like to speak to this I
think that uh in general
um
New Hampshire voters are very
conscientious and careful and fill in
their ballots very well
there are also instructions on filling
in your ballot at the polling place
this bill seeks to complicate things in
a way that I don't feel is necessary
some of the marks that were that are
suggested
um
could that that the the bill the author
says would be interpreted as a no Vote
or a yes vote rather could be a no vote
actually in my opinion such as a voting
Target being filled in all the way and
then x's on it
those are cases where the voter really
ought to get a new ballot and that kind
of education should be increased to
solve this issue if it's truly a problem
but not
this bill as it's written
that's I don't feel that's the best way
to solve
a problem that's I find to be quite
small as well
further discussion representative
Kennedy
yeah I I think this bill uh
representative McGuire was
um he's only talking about recounts and
I think he's only talking about ballots
that are challenged
and I think all he was trying to do was
take some of the variability out of the
individual judgments of the people
looking at the ballot and narrow that
down a little bit by giving guidelines
these are not rules or you know
the hard and fast
so I you know maybe it's not that
valuable but you know I didn't think it
was worthless
further discussion
representative Handler thank you Mr
chair uh uh yes so I agree this bill is
not really needed
um at the hearing this uh deputy
secretary of state testified that the
Secretary of State already has the
authority to give guidance that we don't
really need a law
um
as far as how to interpret the markings
on the ballots
so
uh so thank you
all right anybody else
okay the motion is
an experience a legislate on House Bill
495 call it
representative purdom O'Brien yes
representative boom yeah
representative qualey yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Brenham yes
representative Kennedy yes
representative Dunn yes
representative wood yes
representative pamonte
yes
representative Wayne yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative Meerhead
representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Smith
yes
20-0
and I made clear marks no Sons no stars
or smiley faces
for the record
anybody object to consent
okay
well news action session on House Bill
590 representative Bowman was recognized
from Ocean
anybody got us back
I'll second that
would like to speak to your motion
well we know a lot of
dirty tricks going on
um
I already tricked on down with signs
we've seen them in the last election
seen them in a lot of past elections uh
this however may be a
a problem with with the Court's First
Amendment and so
I don't know
um
but we've seen you know like KKK Airline
uh the candidate is against this when
actually they're for it and and all that
including a state senate race some years
ago where the sign was up for
so and so was Ford higher taxes and when
actually wasn't and the sign's been left
up for months so that's why I you know I
put in the bill because of all the you
know
trying to keep things fair but anyway
thank you
representative Howard
thank you Mr chairman I think
representative boehm uh alluded to what
my concern with this bill and that's the
first amendment concerns I think that
there could be the case where uh the
signs could be used in a satirical uh
Manner and in that instance if they're
trying to provide uh information in a
satirical format they should not be
punished for doing so
representative Brian thank you I also
have First Amendment concerns but what
changes it for me with this bill is
where it says it appears to be the
candidates advertising that may be
removed by the candidates so it's not
just someone's opinion it's a hidden
opinion it's an opinion that is meant to
confuse voters I I don't I don't I don't
like that that doesn't fit for me so I'm
going to be
uh supporting this bill for that reason
representative girl
yeah to speak to the um appearance to be
the candidates advertising
um you know I mean we currently have
parity in in the political world of all
forms people dress up as their favorite
or their least favorite candidate and
make fun of them on late night TV
um you know people write satirical
letters to the editor there's many
examples I could name
um I do agree with
um
my colleagues who introduced and support
this bill I don't think it's a good
practice I don't think it's you know
good campaigning um kind behavior
um certainly not you know how I chose to
run my campaign but unfortunately or you
know fortunately we live in a country
where the First Amendment does give us a
lot of latitude when it comes to the
type of speech we put out there and I
think while it's not good practice and
you know we should
you know try and move away from those
kinds of behaviors I think it's more
important to avoid
um
you know restrictions on freedom of
speech
further discussion representative
Muirhead
thank you I think this there's a common
sense to this bill but I'm concerned
about the difficulty here of legislating
common sense in this this qualification
that you can remove advertising with
your name on it if it appears to be your
advertising
raises the question who gets a judge
whether it appears to be your
advertising so if there's a sign out
saying your head hates kittens
and I want I go and I pull all those
signs it could be arguable that's
obviously not your advertising it
doesn't even appear to be your
advertising because you would never put
up signs that said that so so there's a
I think a just a hard to write the rule
that becomes a law problem here
representative
thank you Mr chairman I sympathize
deeply with the aggravation and
frustration that can be caused by the
type of advertising we're discussing
here
however I believe that in a time when it
seems people are frequently
quote canceled unquote from participal
participation in Civil Society
that we just because of speech that some
found offensive that we need to draw a
bright line here
of no compromise with our Free Speech
rights that are guaranteed by the First
Amendment thank you
further discussion
all right hang on
I love it when we write rules for things
that all of us do that are illegal but
so this bill only applies to
political advertising on public property
like when we all pepper the size of
State highways I'll snap without getting
the abutting property owner's permission
as we're required to
and then we have the nerve to complain
when somebody takes those signs that
were placed illegally and we've even
written in protections that other people
can take the signs only the municipality
and Dot sorry pontificating it annoys me
okay so the way this is written the idea
is it's fake advertising I mean
political advertising on public property
bearing the candidate's name and that
appears to be the candidates advertising
so
however you feel about kittens you
wouldn't admit it publicly so that
wouldn't be your advertising
a good example
I don't know why we're worried about
science so much because the best example
was uh
three or four presidential Cycles ago
when
Republicans put out ads
that looks like they were coming from
democratic candidates to
skew the output out
put of the primary and then they said
huh that was a good idea and I think did
it with a lot of other offices and the
last one but Democrats that it's
Republicans were all guilty every
anybody get up on a pedestal
this seems pretty clear though
I don't know it's probably a lawyer
Reform Act but I think I understand what
he's trying to do and I've seen examples
of it if you're a Republican
representative Stephen Smith voted for
an income tax
we've seen door hangers that do that and
that's not public property so it
wouldn't matter
um
I don't know what we've done to the
other side but I'm sure somebody did
something
I don't know I like the idea of trying
to stop it so
it doesn't seem ambiguous to me
further discussion
representative Brennan
thank you
um the part for me that appears
ambiguous is actually the word appears
um that appears to be the candidates
advertising
who decides what appears to be the
candidates advertising and how do you
determine if the candidate
is accurately interpreting the sign to
be in their own likeness
in their own advertising likeness
it is a little bit ambiguous and you may
run into a situation where a candidate
is
simply just does not like a sign that
has their name on it and removes it even
if that sign does not
look like their own personal advertising
so that ambiguity
is problematic while I understand the
intention behind this bill
um
the language here
I think is enough of a problem
and the First Amendment free speech
part of it is a little bit of a problem
too so I would urge my colleagues to
vote against the ought to pass motion
thank you
president
aye representative
thank you Mr chair so here we're talking
about political advertising which is
very clear
um about like how that will be
conveyed to the public and there is a
paid for uh byline at the very bottom of
the sign I mean you could put it
anywhere you want but it has to be on
there so if you really have a doubt
we're talking about public property you
could walk up to it see who it's paid
for by and go that route I don't see why
we would carve out an exception this
would be the only case that I'm aware of
where you could go and legally take
political advertising I I just don't
think it's appropriate
representative Howard
thank you Mr chairman uh if you all
entertain me in this scenario let's say
hypothetically I decided to run for
state senate in a few years and one in
an opponent of mine decides to put out
in a sign before I've created any
campaign literature that says
representative Howard you know let's use
the income tax for example voted against
income tax if I decided to
emulate that political advertising would
then I be given the right to remove
their uh false advertising if I did not
vote against income tax
the specifics of your question would be
why would you think it was your
political advertising it referred to you
in the third person
again I mean I was throwing a
hypothetical out there as the you know
after Bob Dole right yeah that's okay
for the discussion
okay
well I don't know what you're gonna do
if you pass this though just think how
busy the Court's gonna be and I want to
watch that
so the motion is ought to pass
on House Bill 590 call it representative
prudhome O'Brien
representative boom yes
Representative qualey no
representative Ankerberg no
representative Burnham no
representative Kennedy
representative Dunn yes
representative wood no
representative pamonti yes
representative lean no
representative Ward no
representative Hamer no
representative Hamlet
no
representative mirrorhead
representative Bay no
representative Brennan no
representative Grill no
representative Howard no
representative Palmer no
representative Smith
yes
that is one two three four five years
and 15 Nays
and the motion fails
looking forward to the political ad I'm
representative Stephen Smith and I'm
protecting you from the First Amendment
so
somebody's got to do it representative
lame
foreign I would like to remind
representative Muirhead
I'm sorry what
I would like to remind representative
Muirhead because I don't want to write
another report
[Laughter]
what does that make a motion please to
itl because I'm your head moves ICL we
could at least second it for him though
you want to talk about it
I I really appreciate the debate to this
point no need to add to it thank you
like your style all right
the motion is an expedience to legislate
on house
bill
590s no I was letting her finish filling
out the form it's like speaking really
slowly
appreciate it okay ICL on 590 go
representative pronomo Brian no
representative boom no
representative qualey yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy
representative Dunn no
representative wood yes
representative pamonti no
representative Lane yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative Moorhead
representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Smith
no
that is 15 to 5 on itl
and the Motions adopted
so I voted with you rebels but we're not
doing a Minority Report are we
no no no good thank you
oh foreign
all right well
um we will meet next Tuesday to finish
our house bills all our public hearings
are done that's just exacting we're
going to do it at 10.
you guys have been moving pretty
efficiently so I don't see why we can't
get done by lunchtime and that'll be it
until we got some Senate bills thank you
all see you next week
okay
oh and those reports
um I'm going to make a mistake and say
that I need them by 11 tomorrow instead
of today since we hear this late